[Laughter]
thank you
hey everybody what's going on it's
Friday night yeah Ally was asking about
Pookie Pookie's right there and we've
been playing with her she ran up to me
now she's she ran up again
yeah makes her a little Trill noise
I thought she wanted to play throw I
threw the little toy mouse and she just
watched it hit and then looked back at
me
I did it again twice and she just
watched it hit and just looked at me
because yeah
she has to be in the proper frame of
mind for a throw she was asking me to
throw it though I could tell by her face
she just wanted to see me throw it yeah
you know she didn't want to catch it
she's like I'm too lazy to catch it yeah
I just want you to throw it and I'll
just watch it hit the ground yeah she's
got me trained yeah she's like oh she
totally does she's like you did a good
job she knows exactly what'll piss me
off she'll run up and [ __ ] start
pulling on a damn Shades because she
knows I'll get up and stop her and it'll
start a wrestling match
I got holes in the damn Shades where her
claws went through it because she knows
it's loud yeah she knows it's loud she
shakes it she looks back at me like I'm
not supposed to be doing it but I'm
doing it so I'm running up come get me
come get it yeah
she's [ __ ] funny man and and what's
what funny about her is that the worst
thing you can do to her is blow on her
if you blow water she screams it's like
you're throwing boiling water on her she
just
going
like that she's
a hold of her while you're blowing on
her it's even worse because she can't
get away
I think that's why she hates that
ceiling fan yeah yeah it's like it's
killing me oh my God I know you're just
like yeah it's just like that it's like
that demon from exorcisted Birds
throw the holy water on it you know
Danny rolling asks is that is that a wig
or did you dye your hair uh yeah it's a
wig I've had this wig for a long time I
just haven't worn it in a long time
because it's long and it's like you know
it's kind of hot uh you know I mean
we're going out after I don't think I'm
gonna wear this one I think I'm gonna
wear the shorter one because like if I
try to dance to this it'll get caught in
a [ __ ] thing
yeah mango said dogs react the same if
you blow on them yeah I don't understand
what glowing is such you know what she
did the other morning she woke me up at
six o'clock because I guess she had
eaten all her treats that we left for
her and she was mad and so six o'clock
in the morning I hear
yeah so I think she got up on your side
of the bed and like threw something off
or something I don't know what she did
but it was loud the worst thing you
could ever do to her is to grab her back
leg and blow on her foot
she's [ __ ] loses it she can't believe
it that you did it and when and she
tries to get away but when you get that
go over she runs and then comes right
back and falls on the ground like do it
again yeah
[Laughter]
[ __ ] funny man well she kind of does
it's like a weird little game she plays
it's like she'll jump up on the bed and
then like she'll She lays like that with
like her little feet sticking out the
back tempting you'd grab tempting you to
grab him because she knows that Daddy
will grab them yeah and then she's like
stop it stop it stop it and she'll like
tuck him in and then she gets mad and
runs away but then she comes back and
does it does it again yeah
footsie games
don't grab my feet game
game yeah like a little kid she is like
a little child yeah
all right so we're uh just
sitting here on a Friday
forming everybody up Friday for uh a
night out we're gonna we're gonna go out
to the to the club and go to mannequins
yeah drink in
um
lemonade and uh
whipped cream vodka
from uh Pinnacle and it tastes just like
lemon icebox pie or key lime pie like
that yeah it's just like
granther says uh Robert Eggers is in
discussion to direct the next Thor movie
another great Indie filmmaker going lame
stream like
I get it like you know I'm sure like the
money is nice but man Robert Eggers
movies are so cool and it's like they're
so weird
and I just kind of hate it when they
always get like a weird filmmaker like
that and they're like here make this
Marvel movie or whatever it's Thor wait
is Thor Marvel or DC I don't know I
don't even remember Marvel yeah Marvel
movies are getting bad I think you know
I never really liked them to begin with
but they're getting more and more
generic uh although I heard Doctor
Strange is pretty good
yeah everybody was talking about that
because they said it was almost like a
horror movie like like I said I like
because I like that doctor strange
character I like Benedict Cumberbatch
evidently Moon Knight sucked I think was
it Moon night no what was it was it was
the damn uh morbius that's what it was
the best supposedly sucked yeah it's
weird because it's like we saw the
trailers for that and I was like that
looks pretty good it looked awesome in
the trailer and uh yeah but then it came
out and everyone was like all right so I
don't know
I you know like I said I haven't seen it
so I can't really I kind of think the DC
stuff was a little bit better recently
um from what I saw uh although I liked
the spider-verse stuff and some of the
in that last Spider-Man was pretty good
yeah I like that too I had Doctor
Strange in it and all the old bad guys
from the old Toby Maguire had everybody
in it it's like a spider verse type
movie that was really good all the
spider peeps yeah and the animated into
the spider versus pretty good yeah I
like that a lot
um
I like [ __ ] Shazam uh and then they
say Black Adam is really good supposed
to be excellent I'll I'll uh I'll read
it when it comes out for to for red I
mean it's out now but it's twenty
dollars yeah I mean you gotta wait
if you wait like a few weeks though yeah
there were people it'll be down to 5.99
there were guys that I trust like from
off of midnight Midnight's Edge
that Swedish guy he's got good taste I
like his taste and he was real skeptical
and he he saw it he loved it I thought
it was great
um
so you know the rock [ __ ] he delivers
he produced I think he produced or
helped produce Shazam too yeah he was
somehow involved yeah yeah Mega said
Black Adam is awesome yeah yeah for her
so I'm gonna see that
uh yeah because I really like Shazam too
I think we saw that in the theater a
couple times actually yeah
now um
I [ __ ] liked the Joker even though I
really could only bring myself to watch
it once uh I think Louie bought me
another copy on Blu-ray I'll see it
again soon that movie's torturous to
watch just because that motherfucker's
so pitiful but um it was an epic movie
and I was really hoping that that new
Batman was kind of in that same universe
but it isn't that was still pretty good
though it was still it was okay yeah the
new Batman was okay it was just a
different spin on it you know a little
more primitive not so technophiliac
which I like that you know um I mean
Batman's got too much technology it's
just not
it starts to strain credulity although
it is the style you know like yeah I
mean it is a comic book it is still but
that's that um
uh that Dark Knight series I liked it
matter of fact I'm I'm in training and
putting together my next bang costume I
posted it
um I'm gonna get that bang mask and
I can I can I look better than that
shirtless I don't even need the vest
a good there's copy vests out there for
about 70 bucks
but from what I've seen the quality
isn't that good
you really want to get the replica and
they got a woman that makes those
replicas but you're talking several
Grand I mean it's a [ __ ] badass
armored vest I got
real vast real bulletproof vest they're
kind of close to that
but I could probably just go shirtless
with with his armbands
um he had a he was wearing two pistol
belts one above the other which I have
one of them I just got to get another
one and that would I could do that
version of it
there's a bunch of different masks
though rage ranging and quality
seems like a lot of them are twenty
dollars they were [ __ ] terrible then
they got 50 ones that are okay then
there's a 300 one that is a replica
um but I don't spend 300 on damn ask
um some guys are making them
which uh maybe I might be able to pull
that off make it out of leather or
something but I don't know maybe that or
get the fifty dollar one and if there's
any problem with it modify it yeah that
might be the best probably the best way
to do it because then you'd at least
have like a foundation right Ali said
Jenny love your glasses thank you very
much yeah I was just Tom got me those
yeah I got her these two but they're
just which like I said I was skeptical
because I was kind of like well I don't
know if I'm into like this big ass
glasses like that man there's a lot of
it we'll see but that but see the thing
about it is like you know but I was like
I don't know if it would look good on me
though is what I'm saying like I don't I
don't really care how hip something is
yeah I'm just kind of like I want to
know if it's gonna look good on me or
not because I don't look the same as
other people I think you look good on
you yeah they do I didn't think they
would but like I said try those on yeah
okay but I can't see you don't need to
see just try them on for a second
because those ones are reading glasses
these ones aren't these are just
costumes yeah yeah and now it's oh now I
got hair underneath my glasses I like
those too yeah I don't know what I can't
see what I look like what do you guys
say I mean you know you guys can drop a
comment you're all blurry turned the
other way so they can see it from
different angles yeah I think they're
cute
I might wear these out yeah I think
those would look really good in the club
I'm not gonna wear this wig though I'm
gonna wear this short I'm gonna wear the
shorter blue one because this one's like
I said this one's long yeah it's fine
when I'm just sitting here but when I'm
out moving around it catches and
everything that would look good with the
outfit with pads and a top and yeah
that's what I'm doing I'm just gonna do
this yeah I'm gonna do um big boots and
stuff at the cube I'm just gonna do some
pants and yeah that's what I would do
like a pants in your like vest or your
you know what I mean yeah I have well
yeah I have like a sleeveless kind of
yeah that's like velvet and then I might
put the um did I actually have it worn
before yeah
yeah yeah do it what'd they say uh I
don't know I got planned hold on uh
um
oh Louise yeah Louis made a good point
he said I'm not a big uh comic film fan
but they do allow the studios to make
Indian art films yeah that's the good
thing about them is that they make so
much money that you know maybe they'd be
willing to like throw some more money at
like movies that maybe aren't like a big
thing so that's good I thought they were
stupid not to do another Joker well they
were but like I said you know what are
you gonna do
well the thing about it is that and
we've talked about this before it's like
it's amazing that any movie gets made
because of like the giant [ __ ]
and everything and I mean even like I
said when we were talking about I'm
forgiven that I put up earlier today I
was like [ __ ] the idea for that movie
was like kicking around since like the
1970s and that's how long that it took
like to get made just for various other
reasons like stuff gets kind of talked
about and made and then it's like ah we
don't really want to do that or the
rights revert or some other kind of [ __ ]
mango said going left field I recently
got around to watching Tusk yeah well
now hmm yeah curious movie yeah it was
great though I really liked us but it's
one of those movies that's like very
very love it or rated you know what I
mean yeah like if you if people hate it
I understand that it's fine but um I
don't know there was something about it
I really liked I still haven't seen um
because I know there's another one uh
yoga hosers and I still haven't seen
that I've heard that one's awful but a
lot of people didn't like Tusk either
and I really liked tusk
you know yeah I tend to live really like
weird movies but the thing about it is
that
sometimes
sometimes a movie can be weird just like
for the sake of being weird and I think
that's kind of like a subjective
uh assessment that everybody kind of has
to make because I mean for example if
you didn't see like a couple days ago
um or yesterday or whatever I put up a
review of that movie braid from 2018
which is one of those movies that is
like super divisive like among people
that actually saw it which didn't seem
to be that many but these people either
really really loved it and thought it
was a masterpiece or just thought it was
like not stupid but they just thought it
was
um you know just a bunch of style over
substance or you know weird for the sake
of being weird like just being acid
trippy and like nonsensical but I don't
know I really dug it but you know I can
understand like people that didn't
because you know like I said movies are
subjective I like real weird [ __ ] like
that but I know some people don't and
I'm not I'm not hating
Danny Rowling said Tom dressing up as
nemesis from Resident Evil would be sick
I don't know that character yeah you
have to look it up
uh Zach said I find big 70s type glasses
actually look real good on people so I
like it it depends because honestly like
I remember the 70s and to an extent the
early 80s because if you weren't there
like the 70s kind of carried over into
the early 80s yeah halfway through it uh
yeah pretty much uh so some people like
were wearing the big glasses and I
didn't think they looked very good I
think it depends on the shape of your
face it was the rims that they were
wearing back then and also the outfits
they wore along with it it made them it
looked bad and they had bad hair a lot
of people in the 70s that too had bad
hair that too depending it all depended
on what it was and a lot of the girls
didn't wear makeup and they were the
kind of girl that needed makeup probably
or it was makeup that was like real
cheap and it was like kind of yeah
Soviet looking makeup [ __ ] yeah
because they didn't really well they
didn't really have I mean I guess they
did but it was like really expensive but
like I kind of feel like nowadays
you can get like reasonable good quality
Cosmetics for not horribly expensive
yeah whereas I don't really know if you
could back then I feel like the cheap
[ __ ] back then like looked like cheap
[ __ ] yeah it did yeah that's what I'm
saying like I you know that it's at
least from what I remember it looked
like something a little girl would wear
today at one of those little playsets
that that actually those that's probably
better now than it used to be but
remember some of those colors were just
garish yeah garish colors that didn't
look good didn't match
and um you know some
some women could afford nice stuff and
companies that had you know decent
shading pallets and stuff to choose from
but that's just not
you know people forget that the compared
to what you have right now in the 70s
and the 80s the United States would be
kind of today considered to be kind of
like if you were to go back in time it
would look like a third world country to
you a developing Nation because that's
the way a developing Nation looks now
well you didn't have the selection back
then because I don't know like some
people yet when it was Halloween like
people like me that were like into goth
and stuff like that you had to stock up
you had because that was the only time
that They Carried like black nail polish
or and it was like shitty black nail
polish you know what I mean yeah or like
any kind of like weird colored you know
uh eye shadow or anything red or
anything like that you had to wait
unless you wanted to like order it from
manic panic like you could do that but a
lot of times that was kind of like
pricey better product selection
fast delivery unlimited selection it's
just
and the quality is good for a real low
price and that's just that was unheard
of in the 70s and the 80s given things
that were kind of mediocre looking when
you look at them today were expensive
back then yeah like a little
walkie-talkie okay the little
walkie-talkie that
um uh from that what that that oh what's
his name from um
from
[ __ ] man [ __ ]
what's the name of that movie Chris
Christmas movie that's an action movie
die hard yeah Bruce Willis he spends
half that
movie talking into a
into a walkie-talkie
that walkie-talkie if you can find it as
a collector's item there's they didn't
sell that many of them
and uh they were expensive but guys got
rid of them because they went obsolete
they weren't digital they were
transistor and they had mechanical
selections on the top but because that
was featured in that movie so much
it's worth a lot of money now all right
uh it was worth a lot back then that was
like something that would probably be
like 100 something bucks in 80s movie
80s money which that was a lot of money
in in the 80s late 80s
today you could get a radio that will
totally outperform that thing by about
four times it's digital
for 20 bucks
yeah 20 bucks that's just far outstrips
that 100 radio from back then
and uh if you were to move that back in
time and show them it's called radio on
a chip there was no transistors it's
just a it's just a chip inside of a body
and a battery
you can print them out by the millions
militaries are using them
for a little Squad radios
they're only like two watt radios but
you can get them up to about 10 watts
but that's more than a prc77 we used to
carry around anyway
um that little radio can outperform
anything that they had back then
you know for twenty dollars and then
just they think that was like someone
from outer space with a digital display
and buttons like on a push button phone
man we had the numbers back then on on
little ham radios were
dials you know what I mean it had like
six dials so you could push in
you know like remember how you know the
dials would be like a volume control
yeah because they were like that they
had
10 digits a zero and a zero to nine you
know and that's how you entered in the
frequency that you wanted to now you're
just punching a number and it's
displayed on the screen you know just
can't believe that technology changed so
much in my lifetime
it improved yeah it's crazy quickly and
you didn't really notice it at the time
well like I said because we were there
for the whole thing it wasn't like we
were like in a coma for 30 years and
then woke up and be like what the [ __ ]
is all this [ __ ] now
um granther says oh somebody asked me if
I'd seen the lobster I haven't seen it
yet um but it's on my list because yeah
I definitely do want to see that grandpa
says what are the three weirdest movies
ever
his picks are blue velvet Quiana scottsy
and Tommy
uh he says I'm a big fan of the who love
the songs but the movie is whack
um honestly like blue velvet to me like
I love David Lynn she's my favorite blue
velvet to me doesn't seem that weird
that's like that's like not even David
Lynch's weirdest weirdest movie
um I do like koyana scottsy though and I
think they did another one too didn't
they do another one we're the weirdest
movies Eraserhead
yeah I think David Lynch's weirdest
movie is probably a racer raise your
head or Inland Empire Inland Empire is
pretty [ __ ] weird too
and then um I'm trying to think it's
like huh
weird movies I've seen a lot but it's
just kind of like I'm not really sure
maybe Beyond the Black rainbow that was
pretty weird
um
like I said braid was pretty weird
although it's like that's not even like
on the spectrum of the weirdest [ __ ]
that I've ever seen I thought Human
Centipede was weird and disturbing
yeah
yeah to me it was just I don't know it's
it was a it was a good concept but it
was just like gross I kind of just like
I kind of didn't know what to expect I
didn't know it was good that far you
know what I mean it was like oh [ __ ] you
know that one that one [ __ ] bothered
me yeah
um
what about Holy Mountain I remember that
one oh that's a [ __ ] that's a weird
ass movie well actually like any like uh
Santa Sangre that was pretty weird too
the one with no arms with her son being
her arms and stuff I don't remember that
oh I kind of yeah we reviewed it not too
long ago I kind of remember that uh Zach
says have you seen a French throw a card
trouble every day I haven't seen it yet
but that's another one that's on my list
I think they added it to shutter not too
long ago
Pink Flamingos somebody said yeah I mean
John Waters movies are actually a lot of
fun I don't can I don't find them weird
necessarily they're just kind of like
trashy and fun and gross like you know
what I mean yeah like Divine eating real
dog [ __ ] and stuff which you know yeah
oh Richard bounce it in fabric yeah that
was a weird ass movie that was a
fantastic movie I loved in fabric
um but that's kind of like another movie
that yeah it's either going to be one of
those ones where it's like you watch it
like I watch it and I was just like yeah
this is this is a movie just for me I
love this [ __ ] movie but then I think
a lot of people saw it were like what
the [ __ ] you know what I mean it's
essentially about
uh I want to say it's about a haunted
dress but not exactly you know what I
mean that's kind of like the the one
sentence like breakdown of it but it's
actually like so so much more and like
visually it's like really really
it's it's awesome it's almost kind of
like a um
you know what I mean
it's almost kind of like a giallo movie
you know yeah
um nymphomaniac Lars bar chart yeah
there you go and let's see
um they're talking about Lethal Weapon
and die hard being Christmas movies are
fighting over it's not it's a suicide
movie there I have all of them they're
they're they're both good series
um
but wait a minute hold on no I have all
the lethal weapons
I don't have all the die hards I think I
only have the first two
and I think only the first three are
good
if I remember correctly everything after
that was kind of [ __ ] but really I
think only the first one and the second
one were real good I think the third one
was just okay I don't think maybe I
don't have that one but all of the
lethal weapons were okay they were you
know ranged from good to to pretty good
that was more of like a buddy flick
everybody ended up being buddies at the
end I only remember the gangster
to be honest with him they were all
right
they were okay
movies of their time I don't think they
I don't know what that's all opinion I
think I like Beverly Hills Cop one and
two better
three wasn't all that good but one and
two I think were better than Lethal
Weapon
well it kind of had it had a kind of an
indie feel to them
yeah that I liked you know
uh Oscar says review The Cook the Thief
His Wife and Her Lover yeah I've been
wanting to do that one for a long time
too
uh as far as weird movies house that
Jack built yeah that was pretty weird
that was pretty weird
um let's see somebody's asking Fitness
questions yes what's the question uh I
do resistance training three days a week
I'm adding aerobic workouts elliptical
rowing several times a week but I love
wine and though I'm not overweight I
look six months pregnant advice so it's
just supposed to be a female yes
how old is she I don't know because age
is a factor that's true okay everything
has to do with your age
and and what was the what was the what
was the actual question can she drink
wine is that what she's asking no she's
saying that like why if she's doing all
that like why does she still look six
months pregnant even though she's not
overweight she's probably old
65 65 yeah okay you need to be on
hormone replacement therapy there's just
no way to maintain a decent figure
beyond for men beyond the age of 35 it's
a decline women after menopause the
hormone production isn't is very low
it doesn't matter how much you how how
little you eat you're gonna start
looking dumpy or male or female like
especially around the middle you do kind
of like start to gain some and well like
it's different for everybody but um you
know kind of my grandmother was like
really thin her whole life and actually
she didn't start gaining a little bit in
her midsection until she was like
probably 70. yeah well that you know
what that is that's she's got good genes
that allow her to produce a lot of
insulin right if you can produce a lot
of insulin insulin acts a lot like a
steroid some guys that are bodybuilders
will also add insulin into their steroid
uh [ __ ] regimens
uh because it it helps you get bigger
and leaner
on top of that steroid stack
um
people who are uh East Asian you know
the Japanese Chinese Korean they came
from empires of rice anybody who did not
have a good system for producing
um insulin has long been weeded out of
their gene pool pretty much they they
don't really have diabetes
and they remain pretty thin even on a
pretty
fat rich and protein-rich diet they can
remain pretty lean all right
um not Caucasians or African based
people
our genes are not real good for insulin
production
the body's response to high levels of
insulin is to well have diabetes one and
two start getting fat you just can't
break down that sugar so your body just
stores it as fat
especially as you get older
so you want to go on hormone replacement
if you hit if you're a man you hit
adrenopause
I hit it late 40s early 50s
stress help accelerate it during that
time
um women when they hit menopause it's
the same thing basically
um your hormone production kind of shuts
down or it's a fraction of what it was
you can start getting fat unless you
have
genes that produce to help you produce a
lot of insulin and that'll kind of keep
the weight off you for a while
if you're a woman you want to take I'm
not a doctor I'm not giving medical
advice but a doctor would tell you who
is in the hormone replacement therapy to
take about 20 milligrams of testosterone
a week don't [ __ ] with those gels or
anything if I could inject it inject
that [ __ ] like a man all right uh
and then um
you might want to look into HCG which is
a pituitary gland stimulant I've done a
lot of it it's [ __ ] great all right
it alleviates a lot of problems like
heartburn and any hormonally
problems you know now in a woman it can
restart your menstrual cycle if you
if you do too much of it you might want
to do the research how much a woman
should take
for hormone replacement
and another one that you can take
this progesterone
a lot of women a lot of their system has
to do with progesterone
now there are some women progesterone
something kind of expensive depends on
what your insurance is like and
if you have a doctor that'll prescribe
it if it's not insured you can buy it
you can go to what you call a
hormone replacement clinic or hormone
therapy clinic near you Google points
you in that direction you just go you
hormone replacement therapy near me
Google it it'll show you where they are
see if they're set up for dealing with
women
um
you can learn the ropes there but the
shit's expensive and eventually what
ends up happening is people are in there
for about a year or so and they learn
the ropes they learn what's normal and
what it is they need and they [ __ ]
start finding it a lot cheaper in the
black market
but you got to be careful because you
got to make sure that the where this is
coming from in the black market that
it's really what you're buying you know
and you say yeah that's testosterone it
turns out it's not really testosterone
it's Deanna ball or something you don't
know so you you want to make sure that
the source is good
if it's coming from
coming from maybe uh other countries and
it's in it's packaged when you get it
you know you want to watch you don't
want to get anything that's
from a local
basement laboratory you can't unless you
have the kits they do sell kits to test
all the the purity of all that stuff
um it's just it's just so much easier to
buy something that comes from a known
a known laboratory something with a
brand name a Carl scoga or something
uh which is over the counter stuff in in
certain countries
but there's a weird [ __ ] that you can do
if you're going to be on hormone therapy
you're going to be out for the rest of
your life coming off of it you're going
to get even fatter
so once you're on you got to make a
commitment to stay on and if you're on
that that means you can take steroids
you can jump on and off steroids without
having to worry about the negative
aspects of steroids because there's a
lot there's negative aspects especially
if you're young and you're trying to do
this on your own
endogenous hormone production I don't
have an endogenous hormone production
anymore so it's all synthetic it's all
my hormones have been replaced with
synthetic Alternatives which are a lot
better all right
steroids is certain the doses it's
certain types and in certain regiments
will heal you up
and kind of rebuild you quickly
and the cost is pretty low and it
expands your lifespan you don't die
sooner you die later because you're
avoiding obesity and you're strong
enough to fight off disease you know
there's dudes are doing what I'm doing
died in their 90s like Jacqueline
they got guys in their 70s that look
like they're [ __ ] 50 or 40. you know
or 30. I mean dude's 72 you know
but all those celebrities on there the
Rock and Jason Statham and all these
guys that these dudes are looking at
none of that's natural they're doing
what I'm doing
Zach says have you ever seen a 70s
British drama called Sunday Bloody
Sunday I have not I've heard of it but I
haven't seen it uh Louis said Jenny I
really enjoyed your review of The Night
Stalker and the night Strangler thank
you I remember seeing those movies as a
kid those were the days the movie of the
week on network TV were really good yeah
I kind of feel like most of the stuff
from Dan Curtis and uh you know Richard
Matheson and all that kind of stuff
going on back then there were some
really really good TV horror like in the
70s I like a lot of those TV horror
movies they were like really really
creepy
um I'm kind of gonna do like maybe for I
hopefully if I have hot time to do it
tomorrow but I'm gonna do like a nature
run amok kind of thing I'm going to talk
about Empire of the ants and food of the
Gods and maybe Kingdom of the spiders
but I'm not really sure but if I have
time to like watch all of them but yeah
I agree with you Louis the the Lethal
Weapon series is better than the Die
Hard series it is in term when you talk
about the whole series yeah
yeah Lethal Weapon you can watch like
all four or five of those movies and
there isn't a bad movie in there
if I remember correctly like only the
first two or three of the Die Hard
movies were good the rest of them were
kind of
Richard Brown said another weird film
was spring yeah that was a little bit
weird too I think I reviewed that like
not too long ago
uh people are wanting us to to do 13
o'clock bandanas
I never thought about that
Empire of ants is a great Gorilla song
I don't know it's like I just knew it as
like that movie I just was remembering
like all of the [ __ ] uh you know
killer animal movies that were made in
the 70s that I saw so many times as kid
like as a kid like Orca and all that
kind of stuff but
and then I found out the Empire of the
ants and food of the gods are both both
for free like they're streaming for free
on Plex so I was like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna
do both of those Kingdom of the spiders
is like harder to find although I think
that 2B has a rift tracks version
because I think I watched it not too
long ago but John Smith is talking about
sleep so since you turned 40 he doesn't
seem to need as much sleep yeah it
happens the thing is that you don't
sleep as much and you don't feel like
you don't feel as sleepy it's like yeah
I'm okay I don't need any more sleep the
thing is it's just the way you feel you
actually need all that sleep you're just
not able to get it anymore because your
hormones aren't quite the same you go on
replacement therapy you start sleeping
pretty sound again
um part of the
part of the problem with this is that
when you sleep at night you're supposed
to be your hormones
are supposed to be healing the body and
repairing it to get it ready for the
next day and the older you get the less
that happens so a lot of the effects
visual effects that you see in an eight
an aging person actually are kind of
from lack of
repair that comes from sleep you know
lack of sleep you're not getting the
same repair
once I went on my [ __ ] even notice even
my skin got thicker you know everything
healed up
a lot better
so no you feel like you don't need to
sleep but you do
it adds up over the Decades of not
sleeping that well
my problem I generally get real sleepy
around you know 10 or 11. I usually fall
asleep before 11 o'clock but I wake up
between six and seven yeah and the thing
about it is that I usually wake up at
least once because I have to pee usually
twice yeah so and I'll usually wake up
around
two and then I'll usually wake up again
around like four or five I can do that
too and then I can go back to sleep at
seven and sleep all the way to like 11
or noon now see I can't do it I can do
that too once the sun's up I'm I'm awake
it's easy for me to in the morning to go
back to sleep I can do it really easily
yeah and then I'll actually I'll just
lay there I'll actually get better
rested during that sleep than I did to
sleep during the night and and when
you're when you're in a training regimen
and you're on [ __ ] gear
um
get you're not getting big in the gym
you're tearing everything up in the gym
you're getting big when you're sleeping
you wake up you're healed up you're
bigger especially if you're on a [ __ ]
serious stack
Trend below [ __ ] old heal you up [ __ ]
it's seven hours you're totally healed
back up
you could do it again you don't really
want to but you can
Anthony says wait till you're 60.
I'm just gonna go pack on more steroids
Richard Brown said squirm was a good one
I've seen squirm a bunch of times
because it was on uh Mystery Science
Theater that was actually like a really
good Mystery Science Theater uh episode
what a hilarious movie I'm almost 60 as
it is that's only like five years away
so
yeah you're what 53 54 54. something
like that yeah I'm yeah I'm 54.
um Ali says I probably don't sleep as
deeply as I should because I listen to
your podcasts never watch to listen to
YouTube on YouTube yeah sorry we're
keeping you awake yeah
Blaster once said once the sun's up I'm
awake yeah me too Tammy said I've worked
in nursing homes on third shift and none
of those people sleep through the night
what's that
Tammy said she works third shift on
nursing homes yeah
that's the thing it's like yeah
after a while it's like I can only sleep
for like three or four hours before I
have to pee again even if I try not to
like you know drink too much before I go
to sleep but you know what are you gonna
do unless you're sitting down I mean
[ __ ] yeah I'm in shape for my age man
[ __ ]
[ __ ] um
and I built that I built most of this
body in under three years
wasn't it yeah 18. I've been on gear
I've been on no I've been on hormone
replacement for I think 18 months or two
years huh
I don't have any idea yeah and then um
I've been bouncing on and off steroid
Stacks small ones not big ones little
ones for about a year
um about half the time I'm awesome but
it's real mild more like therapeutic
doses
I'm doing a lot less than say like what
the dude who played vain you know Tom
Hardy he did that in a couple months but
he lost it all the faster you gain it
the faster you lose it
you want to gain slowly
over a few years
all based in lift and weights
so you can come off a steroid stack and
you'll keep every bit of it as long as
you're running a testosterone base which
helps you maintain it
if I didn't have a testosterone base I'd
lose what I have right now over a period
maybe two years it probably it's I'd be
in there working out and getting smaller
because you just don't make enough
testosterone I have to know what my
blood works like
you know it was only like a 150
nanograms per deciliter testosterone
normal 20 year old Alpha 20 year olds
about 900.
most of the time on my test base I'm
like 1200 right now maybe 1400.
when I'm on a stack effectively like
[ __ ] 3 000 nanograms I'll be like
that for about six weeks when I was on
that Trend it felt like I was on like
nine thousand it was mind warping that's
how high that test felt it's not a test
though it's just a testosterone like
substance
steroids are all based on testosterone
but they have a higher much higher
overdose point you can take a lot of it
without blowing yourself up or losing
all your [ __ ] hair or
growing hair out of your back which I've
started to grow hair in my bag with
real thick but Jenny you got to [ __ ]
shave my back now
[Laughter]
I turned you into a gorilla
yeah yeah Honky Kong
that's right yeah
uh Anthony said Wednesday's dance is on
a loop are you are you talking about
Wednesday like the character from the
from the show or what
yeah he's talking about that Loop of
Wednesday dancing oh okay that's what
he's got to be talking about they're
making a um is every is that making a
movie no it's a series oh it's a series
it's on Netflix it's called Wednesday
that's what I was just gonna ask it's
like because I was just reading an
article earlier today where they were
talking about
um it was kind of like one of those list
articles about uh
uh TV shows that were like way bigger
hits than anybody expected and Wednesday
is like the latest one of those
apparently so it looks like right up my
alley but I haven't watched it yet so I
don't know but I was like um the other
stuff that was on there I know Wednesday
was on there
um stranger things was on there because
they said they didn't know like if that
Cobra Kai was on there
um and apparent and I didn't know this
was out yet either but apparently the
there's also on Netflix they have that
new series
1899 which is the same people that made
dark which I [ __ ] loved dark that
German show and apparently uh this one
is just as like weird and dense and
everything like that and and yet it is
one of their highest rated
shows so I will probably get around to
watching that too but I do actually kind
of want to see Wednesday it looks fun
okay you guys
the uh isn't it Tim Burton yeah he's a
producer on it and I think he directed a
couple episodes at least what I heard I
wanted to jump in here and tell y'all
something that's been going on recently
part of this has to do with
the time of year it is all right
November December real bad for us when
it comes to uh [ __ ] uh show Revenue
but over the past couple years
Jen is kind of lost about half her
patrons
Patron money she used to get about six
hundred dollars a month in patreon money
now it's down to about 300.
and she's starting to run she just you
know it's it's easier for me to say it
because it's not me but so I'm gonna do
it for she's getting the point where
she tried to compensate for that you
were using ad revenue and opening up new
channels so she's working [ __ ]
Breakneck speed
and uh it's not really working out she's
gonna have to
do one of two things either get some
more patrons
or she's going to have to uh get other
work online
which would take away from Showtime
all right
um we don't know exactly how that would
yeah I'd have to do a lot less videos
right a lot fewer videos a lot and we
might dramatically we might have to
break it back down to only
two videos a week maybe the show maybe
like a side track
maybe uh maybe a a some kind of movie
review because she does too many movie
reviews if you ask me and then the main
show
so what I would like to ask is I would
like to ask
you guys are a hardcore fans who are
watching us live right now right now
there's about 30 of you on here 25 to
30.
if you guys were to help her out and
become patrons even if only at five
dollars a month that would make a big
difference for Jim or if you're already
if you're already on there then it would
be good if you could just like share it
or tell somebody but I mean unless you
already do that yeah yeah you know
[ __ ] uh
you guys have been very good to her and
very generous you know
um if you're already pulling weight
don't worry about it we're just trying
to expand and another thing is is that
some people sometimes a patron will uh
make an agreement but then they change
their ATM card or their bank card or
their credit card they get issued a new
one and the automatic withdrawals I
think stop working yeah sometimes that
may have happened you know I'm kind of
asking you guys to check and to see if
uh if you're patronage is still going
through and and you can read
re-enter in your new card number and get
it so
I just wanted to plug Jen and well I
plugged gen all the time but you're so
gross
I just wanted to uh plugged in Chad's
patreon
um because
um over the past couple years man it's
[ __ ]
it wasn't that bad if we have other
income streams but now we're at a weird
point where two or three hundred dollars
makes a big difference because yeah I
mean because I have other like I have
Book Sales yeah which are more or less
steady
um but I'm getting to a point now where
it's like I wish I had time to like
write another book like a new one right
but I you know I don't have time but
since she had to try to up video
production yeah she can't write the book
so well I mean it might be better where
the money's gonna go it might be better
too like once because I'm in case you
guys don't know I mean I think mostly
I'll probably know but I started two new
channels I have like another horror
Channel and a true crime Channel and I
can't monetize those
until I get a thousand subscribers and I
think one of them has 400 and something
and then the other one has maybe 300 or
almost 400 and so like once those are
able to get monetized that might help
some but the thing about it is that if I
might have to like cut back on those
because as it is like you know we do the
streams we do like haunting Mondays we
do the movie reviews and then I do two
movie reviews and a book review on here
and then I also do two crime videos a
week and two horror videos a week over
on the other channels so I mean and
that's like full time that's like a
full-time thing thank you Jeffy
but that's yeah thank you for all the
work you guys do uh love your other
channels too thank you very much yeah
and it's like I kind of feel like I
don't know I was thinking about this the
other day because I got my uh my crime
videos actually supposed to go up
yesterday but it took like way longer
than I
anticipated so I actually did get it up
but it went up today
um and I kind of want to I don't know
like I'm trying to think like the New
Year's coming up I'm like maybe I need
to like I like doing all the content but
it's like maybe I need to like
streamline it a little bit you know what
I mean maybe I should just do like one
video like for the crime thing and one
video for the horror thing and then I
mean I do like doing all the movie
reviews and the book reviews and
everything like that but it's like I
need to kind of yeah economize a little
bit because it's just kind of like that
it takes too much time and like I said I
have other I have I do freelance graphic
design too which you know is kind of
catches catch can you know what I mean I
never know like how much of that that
I'm gonna get like from month to month
yeah and then the online stores are just
a hit and miss that's just gonna and
then uh recently we've been so busy with
a bunch of other stuff
we haven't been able to ship out the
quarterly shirts in a while sometimes
we'll put the word out hey what what
design do you want what what logos do
you want I don't mean we never hear back
from you guys now some people will get
back with us but if we ask what size you
want
and you don't get back with us then we
assume that you don't really care about
the shirt
yeah
so we don't send it because we're not
gonna send you a random shirt
might not fit right you don't know your
size
be a waste of time and money so you know
some people just want to contribute you
know so if it's over 20. yeah it means
the thing about it it's like I'm I
contribute a little bit to a couple of
other channels patrons and I don't like
they put up like oh Early Access and
stuff I don't really yeah did people
watch any of I don't care I just don't
care you know it's it's nice that they
offer things like I said I give a little
bit to Dan Bell but it's kind of like he
has like a bajillion he does a [ __ ] ton
of stuff too holy crap
um but he has like a whole bunch of
podcasts and stuff on there and he puts
a bunch of those up a week and it's like
I always want to listen to them but I
just never have time but it's like
that's but that's okay I don't I don't
mind you know what I mean it used to be
that we had enough patrons and enough
other income flows that when the slow
months of the year which is November and
December they usually didn't hit us that
hard because super chats almost kind of
vanished during November November which
is understandable because it's like
everybody's like yeah it's hot gifts
it's holidays and [ __ ] you know really
you shouldn't you should shouldn't be
spending money on US unless you're rich
or something because second we we're
we're we're barely trying to get through
the damn holiday seasons well and we
don't have a [ __ ] ton of stuff to buy I
mean honestly we don't well there's you
know I don't really buy stuff for my
extended family like too much it's like
usually I just buy stuff for him I buy
stuff for the kitties the problem now is
the house
that's what I mean by that lawn mower
guess what gonna have to I told you I
made another one I owned a house before
and I told you it's a money suck gotta
get another roof financed to have
somebody about a [ __ ] 10 000 for the
roof yeah and then uh which
next year starting when I that all the
paperwork goes through for the property
tax free because I'm a disabled vet so I
get I don't have to pay property taxes
next year and that should pay for the
roof over a period of about three years
two years yeah because then I don't know
if you know but like insurance companies
in Florida are being real dicks right
now about uh your roof having to always
be less than 10 years old so you have to
like replace it you're right they won't
insure you yeah they won't assure you
then the bank makes you buy their
insurance right and only they are
insured not you type of deal and I don't
really know I don't really know what
they would do to me but they're give
they're they're going to give me time
and the other thing is I got two outside
air conditioning units out there one of
them's pretty new the other one is
getting kind of old it's only a matter
of time for that outside unit fails but
I got that line of credit at Lowe's
yeah so that if I had once the once that
lawnmower is paid off which I was
looking three grand for the lawnmower
you know almost four I think once that
thing gets paid off it's a big old ride
on because I almost got an acre here you
can't have it you got to have a [ __ ]
real lawnmower you gotta have a man's
lawn that's amazing yeah and you're like
well why don't you just hire a lawn crew
they want 200 a month we did have a long
crew in that little place it didn't it
wasn't uh it wasn't expensive here they
want 200 a month to do this acre and the
bushes and all this I'm like well the
long crew at the old place won the lawn
was a lot smaller and two like the we
were renting the place so the owners
that was their crew so we just it was
folded into the rent we just paid like
an extra 100 bucks a month or something
like that right well this way you know
buying that mower was better because uh
it was actually
will end up paying for itself a lot
faster right yeah you don't have to pay
every month you want to pay every month
200 a month I mean the only thing is
it's kind of a pain in the ass I'm gonna
go out there I mean this place has a
giant yeah yard but that that lawnmower
will be paid off I think in another
about six months that's the thing but
like I said I told you interest-free I
mean I owned a house before and it's
just and I and my house was probably
like a third of the size of this one and
even that is like a funny [ __ ] money
suck you had it's like oh does it have
termites like we had termites like
around the back frame of the door one
time and the guys had to come and do
that and then you know a storm came and
blew [ __ ] off the roof and all that [ __ ]
has to be done if you guys never owned a
own a Helm that's this size it's a
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] nightmare it's
stress good thing I'm kind of like a
psycho because I don't worry about it
all times
I think a sane person would be worried
about it all time well see I'm worried
I'm not yeah I do sometimes when my test
level gets low I start worrying about
you like you know like you know what
this [ __ ] is expensive but we've been
here for longer than a year and we've
been making it it's just that shit's
kind of slipping especially during these
during lean months like right now you
know you're like whoa you know the
difference of two or three hundred
dollars makes a big difference right
yeah so you're like you know we didn't
quite really make it you know
credit cards helped out a little much
you know [ __ ] exactly yeah well and
honestly to I don't I don't wanna I
don't want to encourage you to go into
as much credit card debt as I am in yeah
but um you know you haven't had a credit
card for very long and you I don't think
you're seen as a risk it's like I have
like a bajillion credit cards and like
all Max and they won't like give any
give me any more as much as I try you
know what I mean but uh yeah because
they're just like [ __ ] I mean I do pay
them they know how many credit cards you
have I know but it's I mean I do pay
them like on time and stuff but still
they're like girl what is your deal and
before we had to move here one of the
things that was on the list was to pay
it pay off her credit cards I was like
yeah then we had to move you never can
so then I had to get more credit card
like take out more credit cards and like
increase so I had to do that like I said
I do pay them they're not late and then
I couldn't put her on it I couldn't put
her on this deed
yeah that's what I said I was like
absolutely don't put me on this note my
credit is terrible yeah and I also have
I mean it's not terrible had we been
legally married I don't think I'd have
been able to get this place well yeah
I've gone through and went well not with
her credit that's what would happen I
mean it's bad it's not the worst I think
it's in the fair category I don't think
it's in the poor category which is not
great but you know mine was in excellent
well yeah like I said because you never
you've only had a credit card for a
couple of years yeah and I always paid
it right yeah and you pretty much pay it
off pay it off like every month every
month see I don't do that yeah and they
just gave me 500 and then before I knew
it they started to bump it up well yeah
if they pay it they'll keep giving me
more credit and then they asked me if I
wanted another 500 and I was like nah
because they're trying you said no yes
or no because I know I'd use it I'd be
like yeah give it to me no do you want
another five well the thing about it is
that I usually like need it because like
I said that [ __ ] up well the reason
that I got into credit card debt it
wasn't because I was out like living the
high life or anything like that it's
because back before we got together I
got unemployed for a long time and I had
to like skate on credit for like a
couple months like paying my rent and
like paying for my car and [ __ ] like
that until I got another job and then
like you know that happening a couple
times like getting laid off and then
having a couple months where I didn't
have any money and I had to buy
groceries and [ __ ] like that so that's
how a lot of it got run up you know what
I mean it wasn't it was all like
Necessities it wasn't like I was out
like [ __ ] buying fancy [ __ ] or
anything okay so um just like I was
saying reiterate if you just joined us
Jenny needs some more patrons and uh you
guys are the hardcore like 30 they're
always here and if if you guys if you
guys are not patrons I'd really ask you
guys to come make become a patron with
Jenny even five dollars a month would
help and then eventually this these
videos are watched by [ __ ] we have
almost 16 000 subscribers
if just as thirteen thousand thirteen
thousand how was it thirteen thirteen
thousand almost thirteen okay
even even if a small fraction like 20
you guys just gave a dollar or two
as a pitcher doesn't make a huge
difference
make a huge difference for Jim
and really I mean if if you just gave a
dollar out of patriot you still get the
stuff like I don't like I said I put up
like Early Access videos and you can
vote on movies and you can vote on the
topics and you can do that kind of stuff
oh and also I tell everybody like what
the week's video is coming up are gonna
be so you know you also get the password
to our only fan yeah somebody's talking
about only fans
we were talking about that earlier today
and I'm like can we even make money on
only fans anymore yeah right now thank
you thank you very much Blaster one
thank you very much thank you very much
Blaster one Richard Brown said what are
your other channels I have one called
scare salon and I have one called crime
immemorial
and I have been putting two videos up a
week on each one
um but yeah we'll see how that goes
going forward because Tammy's right if
we could just ask people to go subscribe
to those other channels then it would
yeah then because that would help too
because then I could monetize one thing
I did start doing and I know like this
is like [ __ ] maybe people don't care
about it as much as they used to but I
did start putting uh mid-roll ads in uh
the Youtube videos because those give
you like slightly more
yeah uh click through you get like a
little bit more money for those because
a lot of people don't like them and I
didn't put them in for like a really
long time because I think they're
annoying thank you Victor oh for only
fans patreon okay
we'll get some of our ex-girlfriends
over we'll have big [ __ ] foursomes
um I can't have any other boys over it
only has to be girls see that's not it I
figure that's females only
men are very territorial about that kind
of stuff I know but it's like it's funny
the way that it's like dudes will be
like yeah I can just like hump all the
chicks I want but it's like as soon as
their girlfriend is like hey can I have
a boyfriend over they're like no it's
like sexism
would probably be that way yeah
Louise Louise going uh yeah Victor said
I want to see some goth dudes right
[Laughter]
Tony over our my ex my ex-girlfriend and
and her boyfriend her husband that I
gave her I gave her that man remember
I gave her that man I told her that yeah
I gave her that man
um
but uh yeah Louis says he can count him
in too well thanks Louie you've been
thank you very much you've been a great
help to the show anyway with all all the
blue I mean all you guys are I I'm just
like I'm I'm always flabbergasted that
all you guys just like come and watch us
like yapping all the time yeah it's
ridiculous watching us like drinking and
shouting there have been times I'm so
slammed on this [ __ ]
like the next morning I was like I did
[Laughter]
yeah I remember that one and I was just
sitting there going um okay and I was
drinking back the Oasis at the biker bar
and then came here and that's what
happened even more yeah and uh I was
[ __ ] loaded Tom makes all kind of
questionable life decisions yeah yeah
I don't remember I don't remember having
any problem riding a bike back you know
the main flicking well that's the thing
you don't remember but I couldn't
remember it oh I couldn't remember I
think if he woke up in the middle of the
night and he said to me it's like I
don't remember getting back here I'm
like well that makes me feel a whole
hell of a lot better thank you for
telling me that I was checking my wallet
to make sure I didn't leave my ATM card
or my uh my credit card at the Oasis
honestly I've only ever done that one
time one time I have a fear of it I know
I've done that one time and it was at
ibar yeah so they knew I mean they knew
it was me yeah so you know so I just
like I think Lee called me
yeah they called me and said uh Jen you
left your ATM card here last night I was
like whoopsie so I just like what I
drove down there the next day people are
just going over and subscribing to the
other channels thanks thank you thank
you thank you yeah Zach says Tom is a
questionable life yeah
it is you are Tom it is true you are a
questionable life it is true
yeah that's awesome
it's part of my magnetism I was gonna
say it's effort women like the bad boy
they could live with somehow that's so
bad they can't live with it but you know
what I mean [ __ ]
Jenny she's sick of me a lot of times
but she she will admit that I I did keep
I do keep her [ __ ] amused most of the
time most of the most Advocate reviews
she gets mad I woke her up this morning
Paul and at her she put up with it
well I think it was what time was it
seven well no it wasn't because I kind
of went like that and I was like it was
6 30 and I was like which I was kind of
half awake but then I was like man I
would have really like to like lay here
for another half hour yeah but I was
trying to get late I know yeah
I kept trying to scoot over to the side
it's been like stop it
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
and I have to say to say that bed is
really uncomfortable yeah enough like I
can't um we gotta gotta get another one
eventually I know but like I said you
know we can't afford that [ __ ] right now
but
and that big old king-sized thing that
we had that
inflatable it was good but it was just
so old it was just starting to [ __ ]
fall apart yeah
um mango said you guys do one of the
best shows on YouTube oh thank you I
can't tell we don't have that many
subscribers but then just like Jenny
said for like the Velvet Underground of
YouTube
like Jenny said
like Jenny said a lot of the shows that
we watch I look and see how many
subscribers they have and they might
have less than us yeah thank you Grand
Theft money for the Jukebox that they
waste this no Kid Rock songs no yeah
we're not gonna do kids I got the damn
app for the Jukebox at the Oasis he's
like all [ __ ] slick over there like
at the bar and he's like I'm gonna beat
this [ __ ] on everything and then like
sometimes like people be over there like
yelling they're like why is it playing
this yeah yeah
I'm putting a Ramstein
what is this [ __ ] yeah put some
German music in there and then you can
do some [ __ ] up [ __ ] like you can pay
a little bit extra to move your song to
the front of the line and [ __ ] over
better than over see that's not nice
yeah
see that as soon as you don't have time
money corrupts absolutely yeah money
corross people yeah that's right
Victor said I've been around since 2017.
wow I think we only started the show in
2016 didn't we yeah yeah I think it was
maybe summer 2016 Summer or something
like that yeah we went on doing this
[ __ ] a long time this is funny we've run
into people at the club before I don't
even know and they [ __ ] know us
remember that one one time guy said he
was a listener and should he knew all
about us
and I realized that yeah if you stay
with us a long time you know us and we
don't know you
which is it's a little bit weird it's a
little weird yeah I mean I get it
because like I said we're on here like
talking about ourselves all the time so
it's like I felt like I knew Howard
Stern I listened to him everything right
exactly
you know
but see I'm sure like yeah people that
are really famous like that like
obviously you're gonna get like people
walking up to you in the street going
hey blah blah I'm like talking about
this and that well the funny thing too
is that they probably remember [ __ ] that
we said on the show a lot better than we
remember it yeah they do so like
sometimes they'll tell me they'll be
talking to me like I know what and I'm
just like
um did I talk about that on the show
like so we've done so many that it's
like a lot of times I don't really
remember anything specifically when you
host a show when you host a show like
this you have to be just open and honest
you cannot be fake you can't lie
because if you're around long enough
you'll forget what you lied about
yeah it just seems like too much trouble
so much trouble
I've learned by watching other people
it's better to just be who you are
yeah you're a lot more interesting if
you are who you are especially if you're
funny you know if you're funny too
that's even better you we take it it's
serious work to do this gen [ __ ]
works [ __ ] hard to all the technical
behind the scenes stuff as soon as the
camera's rolling you got to have fun
yeah if you're not having fun doing it
if it's too serious you'll burn out
yeah I mean and that's the thing you
know if I talked about other [ __ ] that
was like more popular or something like
that then yeah I guess maybe we'd have
more subscribers or something like that
but it's like I don't think it would be
any fun for me I want to talk about it I
want to talk about cool [ __ ] that I like
yeah I want to talk about murders and
horror movies
she's back
hey
you you're the only cat that is a turkey
just like a turkey cat
she's like [ __ ] you Dad yeah yeah don't
say that she's laying down there with
her feet she tempted me with her feet
she knows she's gonna come down here and
grab my feet grab my feet and then she's
gonna get mad yeah and then I'll get mad
at you blow it on them you know she's
rough she loves to be rough yeah she's a
little tomboy yeah she likes to wrestle
and uh fight and um wants you to chase
her uh wants you to follow her she'll go
Bam Bam didn't you leave the room and
she look over her shoulder come on are
you coming yeah she'll take you
something let's go yeah and then you
follow her and she's happy that you're
following her and she'll [ __ ] take
you in a [ __ ] pattern everywhere and
then she'll lay down and look at you pet
me
so this is about
yeah she's always wanting something yeah
and she gets bored and makes [ __ ] up let
me go get you some more man last night
she was in the bedroom and she she came
in there and we were watching what the
[ __ ] was I watching I think I was
watching Mystery Science Theater or
something
uh because 2B has all the shorts like as
little episodes and I was like this is
delightful so uh I was watching that and
she comes in the bedroom and she wants
to go in the closet she wants to go in
the closet because she wants to tear up
Tom's boots but Tom does not want her to
tear up the boots so he keeps the closet
door closed all the time so she doesn't
get in there and tear them up because
the second he turns his head she kind of
looks as like is he looking no and then
she's like
like she gets in there and does it but
sometimes like when we're in the room at
night she will just like sit there in
front of the closet door and she'll
stare at us really intensely and just
keep yelling and yelling and yelling and
yelling and finally you're just kind of
like fine and you just open it and then
she runs in there and like runs around
but you have to like watch her because
otherwise she'll tear the boots up and
if you're watching her she's like oh
you're ruining it for me and then she
like runs out again and she's like [ __ ]
that it's not any fun if you're gonna
supervise me so you know she's like a
she's like a little child she's really
really smart too
really smart oh you know what she did
the other day this this just shows like
how smart she is she's she's devious so
we have these little um I guess are they
Sheba I guess they're Sheba and they're
like these little meat they're like
Treats but they're like a little meat
stick so it's just kind of like all meat
and it's like you know a stick and a
stick form and she loves those that she
loves them so much that I buy like the
big boxes of them and I have it like on
Amazon like I have a subscription so it
comes like every three weeks or four
weeks or something
and what she does is if she give it to
her she only likes the tuna ones she'll
eat the chicken ones the salmon ones she
doesn't have any use for but the tuna
ones are her favorite and those are the
hardest ones to find and I always have
to order them like chicken and salmon
they have at Publix but tuna they don't
for whatever reason
so what you have to do is she'll come
over and sit by the drawer where we keep
them and she'll stare at you until you
give her one
and usually Tom has to do it she'll take
them from me but she likes she likes Tom
to do it so he'll like hold it out for
her and she gets all into it she'll like
sit there and lick the end of the stick
and she's just like oh I'm like her eyes
are rolling back in her head like it's
the best thing ever and then like she
starts eating it but then like you can't
hold on to it for that long right
because otherwise she'll bite your
fingers so then you kind of like drop it
and then she gets mad at you because you
[ __ ] it up like you dropped it
and so she leaves like a little piece of
the meat stick like on the carpet and
then she gets mad and leaves she's like
[ __ ] this and like runs out the room and
then like later on she comes back in and
wants another fresh meat stick and we
keep telling her no you have to eat the
pieces you have to eat the pieces and
she doesn't want to do it and so last
night she came in wanting another meat
stick and she very deliberately saw that
there was a little piece there and she
sat on it and then looked up at Tom like
hey can I have a fresh one yeah yeah I
pushed her aside and I went and she okay
and she went all right you got me
hey thank you again thank you thank you
thank you it's been a good night you
guys thank you coming through give him
Jenny Christmas present yay see that's
what happens making her feel a little
better yeah that is making me feel a
little better because yeah we forget to
plug the show
that's all that I mean that's the thing
like I'm always having like kind of a
good time and then I'm always just kind
of like oh [ __ ] because I remember like
back in the day we used to have like uh
I had made like commercials and stuff
like that
um but yeah I always kind of forget like
I have it in the description box like
you know like links to the patreon and
to all of our other stuff like our
cookbook and
all our like other sites with the shirts
and everything but it's just kind of
like I don't know I just forgot to
forget to say anything about it and I
think sometimes like if you forget to
say stuff about it I think other people
forget about it too but see I forget too
yeah we're gonna um
be plugging the show regularly on the
regular shows too like on the Wednesday
show probably some of the reviews over
the next few weeks because we just got
to do show maintenance we've been
letting patronage slip there's not
enough patreons
that'll really help peace of mind to
have people even if it's a bunch of
people only given a dollar or so a piece
or two dollars a piece so uh don't don't
let us drive you crazy it's just we have
to we have to conduct some business on
the channel we're getting
money comes from a bunch of different
streams this is the one that's lacking
right now because time of year
the weakness was exposed it was kind of
last year too a little bit in the year
before but I think no just last year
year before I think we were still
I think we still had a lot of patrons I
think the year before so we didn't feel
it that much yeah I mean they kind of
like I said we had the new house is also
an additional crunch we'll see yeah
that's like and that's not on y'all
right yeah but um yeah that was another
and I mean honestly like I like the
house it's just that I kind of feel like
we got a little bit like I don't want to
say we got railroaded into it but I mean
we didn't really have a lot of time
because the landlords were moving into
our old house yeah and they were
basically like well here get in this one
you need to buy it you need to buy it
you need to buy it and they were getting
kind of you know and I was getting sick
of dealing with landlords that too even
though we're the landlords were good we
lived there for like 10 11 years just
get sick of living in somebody else's
house and and having to worry about what
they think of the color of the walls
that I painted that kind of show right
I'm like [ __ ] yeah they weren't big fans
and then we stayed in that house for
nearly [ __ ] 10 years
and we would have had a lot of equity in
that house with what we paid for that it
was more than 10 years I think it was
about 10 years 10 11 years somewhere
around there
had had I been paying on a mortgage I'd
had plenty of equity in that house at
that time well yeah it would have been
almost half paid off bro yeah
uh one-third maybe yeah
um so I'm like I don't want to do that
again because 10 years goes by before
you know it especially when you're our
age yeah so
it was kind of a no-brainer and um
the the kind of like management firm
that they use says no we can get you in
there
[ __ ] and
um they uh told me what to do with my
credit and all the paperwork and [ __ ]
and I got in here
so
I'm happy to get in here because because
I think that's when all this black rock
stuff happened where they started buying
up everything I'm I'm happy to have I
own a house it's real hard to buy one
here now
because people are moving here
so theoretically I might be able to flip
this house in in a while
yeah maybe money on it yeah we'll see I
mean hopefully I don't look at it that
way just you can't count on anything you
just don't count on anything just ooh
everything like slowed down there for a
second that was weird I've never seen
that happen before
uh let's slow down it's just like on the
screen it just kind of a little like
slow-mo for a second it was really weird
I never saw it happen before it didn't
look like the stream didn't cut out or
anything but Victor said I used to
listen to y'all while I delivered Pizza
on the weekends while I was in nursing
school that's like that's really cool uh
Richard Brown said I really enjoyed your
review of the tenant yeah that's going
back a long way too I love that [ __ ]
movie I love that [ __ ] movie
uh mango said the shows are always fun
and they always Sidetrack which adds to
it yeah I kind of feel like it's a mixed
bag some people [ __ ] off the show
he's not adding anything to show get
that [ __ ] off there
well like and I admit I get frustrated
too sometimes well that was I think one
of the main reasons why we started doing
a Sidetrack show because I was like
let's just do a show that's all
sidetracked so we don't have to worry
about and then I won't get upset about
it but it but it still doesn't we still
do Side Tracks on the regular shows
anyway because we can't help ourselves
Victor said there used to be close to
100 people in here when the show was on
Saturday nights yeah that's true yeah I
wonder should we go I don't know it's
like it's really
we have to have it to where
we can move it to Friday or Saturday
that might make more of a worse yeah
Yeah because sometimes we like to go out
on a Saturday see
well yeah that's initially why we moved
it because you know because I liked
going out on Saturday but now it seems
like now that we go to mannequins more
often than we go to the other place
usually now we go out on Fridays because
Friday nights are better at mannequin we
can move this we can move this too I
mean we'll see like I said it's new year
is coming up so I might like change some
stuff around yeah you know what I mean
like just to make stuff easier and more
streamlined maybe we wanted to do some
stuff that involved going outside yeah
we were talking about that too like
field type stuff right like when we have
money yeah the problem is that the show
isn't making enough income yet but if it
turns around in the next couple months
and um everything goes well we might be
able to do that maybe once a month maybe
that's kind of what we were thinking
yeah like maybe in the New Year like
maybe we'll go like on a field trip
yeah like once every month go look at
some haunted place or look at some crime
scene or something yeah that's a like
yeah so like still along the lines of
the show yeah but you know what I mean
or you know a horror movie location or
something like that I don't know because
I feel like a lot of people like those
and that'd be fun because it'd get us
out of the [ __ ] house too
Grandfather said I started watching
early during the pandemic when there
wasn't [ __ ] to do and couldn't leave the
house y'all were a ray of funshine when
not much else was thank you yeah I mean
we do try to like keep it fun you know
Louie said I think my favorite
retrospective is the Legend of Hell
House episode that was one of the first
ones we did yeah that's actually one of
my favorite movies from the 1970s I love
[ __ ] like that when the show was just
a slideshow yeah when nobody even saw
her little faces you guys don't realize
how how labor-intensive that was to do a
slideshow she [ __ ] that drove her crazy
yeah it took forever well that's kind of
like why we only did one or two shows a
week back then because just do it that
like took so long because finding like
having to find like all those pictures
like for however many hours it was doing
it live was a little more natural for me
he grabbed his nose he was in the drama
program with me when we were in high
school going going live is a lot normal
for me and then audience interaction in
the in the chat room it [ __ ] helps a
lot because it does yeah because you
know who you're talking to you know what
the mood is you know how people
responded so and people can ask you
questions in real time and it's just
like so you always have that interactive
element yeah and have it having regulars
into our regulars most of you guys in
there our regulars right now having
regulars is a big help to the show oh
yeah big time because we we can we can
monitor we can it's kind of like having
a feeler in the waters to test the
temperature and the speed of the stream
type of deal you know how you're doing
based on how you're how your uh regulars
are reacted
and how many of them are showing up
yeah Ben says visit haunted crime scenes
where they filmed movies yeah if we
could find some place like that yeah
there might be one in our state maybe
yeah four
four hours away
mango says watch along shows could be
fun pick a movie and talk [ __ ] I've
thought about doing that too like we'd
have to set up the logistics but I do
kind of feel like that might be fun
because sometimes we'll be in the room
like watching a movie and then we'll
make like really funny comments about it
I'm like God damn we should have been
like [ __ ] streaming this probably
yeah because that was like some funny
[ __ ] and people are like miss it it'd be
funny if we could stream it from bed
because we're laying up in bed just
eating snacks
eating snacks and [ __ ] look at the
[ __ ] TV yeah
talking [ __ ] then Pookie comes up and
begs for meat sticks yeah
I can't believe she sat on that means
day yeah I tried to pass she was yeah
she came over and very deliberate it was
like dead on it and sat on it like what
there's no there's no other pieces she's
like yeah can I have it can I have a new
one okay okay but as soon as he like
moved her butt she was like oh I'm
busted yeah
I didn't even have to ask her she knew
it was like okay
shots yeah
that's [ __ ] funny
granther says suggestions to spice
things up call up favored viewers and
chat with them live for all to hear
their stories live shows from the Oasis
mannequins Etc and more stories about
the love Hotel
I
don't know the one that was on Dan Bell
that's the only one I'm thinking of
we have thought about doing a live show
for mannequins although it's like you
wouldn't be able to hear us talking
because it's so loud in there
unless we're right well no I was going
to say at least unless we're out on the
patio but they have a DJ out there too
does this software have the ability to
bring in
um
a caller I'm not sure I'd have to like
uh poke around in there I'm not sure
it's very complicated I bet you there is
yeah I'd have to like yeah I'd have to
like look it up yeah we'd only be able
to do it with somebody who uh
is ready to go into a live stream you
know on their uh some of the micro
microphone and the camera and a decent
decent stream somebody else who does it
um I don't know about Audio Only they
might have something like that
might be easier but then you know it's
probably because there's a lot of live
streams that do that will be like six
people on there talking
well the one that I do the one that I
did I know how to do it it's just I
don't know how to do it on this
platform like the one the show that I
was on the other day I think we did it
through uh stream yard which I which uh
a lot of people use
okay look into it that's all I'm saying
Zach says I'd kill to be on the show
yeah
I said I'd love to yeah I'd love to do
that and chat with you guys okay
love Hotel grandfather's just talking
about uh Steve's basement Circa 1987.
the secret smush room yeah
this mushroom yeah
celebrities went through that [ __ ]
Heidi
Tara
um
oh [ __ ] that one girl I stole from Steve
well I didn't really steal from she
broke up with him but then I scooped the
Cheryl the nurse Sheriff she's a nurse
now Cheryl Remillard
um Gene petrowski
tore them all up that's what it is a
high school man and they were all they
were all cool those are all cool kind of
goth Puck rock girls
yeah and back in those days back in
those days you could you could
there's no big deal to date like three
girls at once
you know well it's not a big deal as
long as they all know yeah you take one
out and then you take the other one out
the next weekend and go back yeah you
weren't going steady well yeah I think
that's kind of like the the thing that
you do like like I said unless unless
you're going around telling everybody oh
you're the only one for me and I'm not
seeing anybody but you're lying to them
that's that's where I have an issue I
don't have an issue about no you go to
the Chinese restaurant with them and
[ __ ] eat Chinese food and then uh go
see a a movie or go and then uh go
[ __ ] Park out on [ __ ] Grosse Ile
remember got Grosse Ile go across the
[ __ ] bit they had a [ __ ] lovers
laying down there I think I think it was
Grosse Ile I think it was the name of
the place and uh having lovers laying
down in their [ __ ] teenagers make it
out of this car so you pull in to be
nine cars in there
half of them bouncing
up and down on his [ __ ] suspension
that's like [ __ ] from like the 1950s
yeah
in the 60s and then yeah and then the
Zodiac would come again yeah
yeah it was all good though man
grandpars remembers
Grandpa's remembers it was funny you
know [ __ ]
you take a girl out one weekend and then
my buddy Steve would take her out the
next weekend and I'd take the one he had
the day before we were just swapping
them off it's like [ __ ] it we're all
gonna go out together and you know
he'd be in the front seat with his
girlfriend I'd be in the back seat with
my girlfriend they were that they were
all our girlfriends though
because we did dating them all
you know I mean in their little circle
so I guess it
'd been weird today looking looking back
on it it kind of was but like I said
they weren't girlfriends they were
friends yeah I don't really think it was
that yeah we weren't going to stay we're
just dating them
and making out with them and doing stuff
with them yeah yeah I mean I thought
that was like pretty much yeah I think
it's pretty basic yeah that's usually
what was it yeah and like half of them
were virgins still but you're messing
around all doing all kinds of stuff
getting head and [ __ ]
making everything but everything but
yeah sometimes you get to do the butt
too well yeah that's that's called the
loophole the loophole
butt stuff doesn't count yeah Zach says
uh by the way I'd love to see you review
women in love the Ken Russell movie huge
influence in the style of filmmaking I
want to do someday that's the one with
the Oliver Reed naked wrestling scene
yes
I've said I remember really liking that
movie but I said not necessarily just
because of that but I just remember it
being a good movie actually I was just
watching something the other day what
the [ __ ] was I watching where they were
talking about that scene
oh I think I was watching a documentary
that's what it was because I remember
when we did that show about video
nasties like a couple weeks back I was
watching a documentary about like a
British film censorship and they were
talking about Ken Russell because he got
into a lot of trouble with his movie The
Devils like with all the stuff about the
nuns and the and the Jesus statue like
[ __ ] the Jesus statue or whatever
um and then they were talking about
women in love and they were talking
about that famous scene the one scene
that everybody remembers with Oliver
Reed and who was the other actor I can't
remember now but where they were doing
that whole like naked homoerotic
wrestling thing that went on first place
yeah like yeah it went on for like a
really really long time Alan Bates
that's right yeah thank you Richard I
didn't see the movie but I saw clips of
that scene and I was going look at
Oliver read his naked ass wrestling with
that man in front of the [ __ ] Zach
you loved it bro
wrestling with him in front of the
[ __ ] I love Oliver Reed he's still
entertaining
they're obviously bullshitting his
[ __ ] look on his face
that's it's a good movie I think it
moved gramper said I could call in with
crazy cop stories
yeah that would actually be pretty cool
uh responding to an execution style
homicide being the target of armed
militia types working the streets of
Detroit stories of stepping in blood and
teeth see just write a book he said
earlier and I forgot to mention it to
you
that Beverly Hills Cop 4 was filming in
Detroit oh really okay yes so now you
know good
yeah hopefully it'll go to Netflix
I imagine Amazon or something
uh Blaster one
um yeah it's crazy there are some
channels that put up crap and they're
getting millions of views I mean that
kind of bumps bums sometimes but
but no then again like there's some
channels that I really like that have
like a lot of views too so
I'm not gonna
but it does seem like stupid stuff does
get kind of like a lot but you know
sometimes I have a CH I go on a channel
and I'm like wow this is actually like
really well produced and like
intelligent and stuff and I'm always
like surprised it has as many
uh that it has this many because usually
I'm always kind of like thinking oh it's
just stupid [ __ ] that people like but
not necessarily not necessarily it has
like millions of
stuff because it's I don't know so much
about you what I don't understand what
you're saying well no I'm just saying
that sometimes I I kind of feel like the
overarching or the general uh idea is
that
channels that are just like stupid get
more subscribers and more views
sometimes they do but like I said a lot
of times though sometimes I'll find a
video that's actually like really
intelligent and well reasoned and stuff
like that and the channel actually has
like millions of subscribers and I'm
like oh well that makes me feel better
because I would have thought oh it's
just stupid [ __ ] that gets that's what
I'm saying look at PewDiePie
he was [ __ ] making almost a million
dollars a month I don't even know if
he's still around yeah I don't know it
was just silly [ __ ] what did he what did
he do even you started off like I know
who it is but I didn't I never watched
his stuff it started off as just was it
gaming gaming started off him just
gaming so I'm not as dumb as I thought
and uh he would just game and say [ __ ]
he was from Sweden and he would say
funny [ __ ] every now and then and he had
pretty good editing editing skills and
good comedic timing but the material
wasn't that special really right and uh
then it went more into
kind of like a little topic kind of like
do the news and then just bag on other
channels and did
he had his own fan base and he would
make fun of his fans he says yes I have
5 million 12 year olds I mean probably
true yeah because he was looking at the
Opera
statistics there's like five million I
mean which isn't insulting because it's
true it seemed like the average is 12
million I'm the average is 12. it
probably is like yes he's like I Got 5
million 12 year olds and then he would
make up raps about him kicking the ass
of a [ __ ] Indian music channel with 5
million 12 year olds with the power of 5
million 12 year olds I mean he did have
some of the [ __ ] was really funny his
raps
I don't know who wrote the rap for him
but it sounded like it was pretty good
made a rap video he might have done the
rap but
[Music]
um
he was in um
in a online War to be number one biggest
Channel on YouTube
between him and a Indian music channel
like from India and I forgot what the
name of that channel was
but that war went on for [ __ ] months
the numbers were he was ahead for a long
time
but eventually the Indian music channel
won out because it's India they got a
[ __ ] huge population yeah yeah and
they don't give a [ __ ] about our stuff
over here probably they got their own
stuff yeah it was it was Indian music
right like the [ __ ] you like the [ __ ] we
listened to in [ __ ] at Fifth Element
at Fifth Element it's like that well
they always have all the TVs and they
have like the YouTube they have all the
YouTube channels of all the Indian music
videos which actually I always sound
like though well I like to watch them
though they're they're good videos yeah
they're all like big production numbers
they look very expensive it's all boy
girl stuff yeah singing and
the girls [ __ ] impressed and he's
[ __ ] such a man you know such amazing
he's such a man and she's batting around
that's another thing I don't like too I
I think too that there's kind of like um
a lot of channels that are maybe more
popular ones that like [ __ ] on other
channels or just [ __ ] on things in
general you know what I mean and I don't
know I'm just not really into that
that's just like not kind of getting it
all day long well I know you could but
it's like I don't I don't know I don't
really like that kind of conflict I
don't want to put that kind of
negativity out into the world conflict
there's enough of that conflict
[ __ ]
whole fans of well you know some of
those channels that I listen to
that that are critiquing what's going on
in the Hollywood System
are almost totally dedicated to a
[ __ ]
just taking a piss out of Disney
for what Disney does
but it's true and they they predict how
you know what the box office numbers are
really going to be with this Disney
movie and then when it happens like
Midnight's Edge does it a little bit
the guy who really [ __ ] um
that's basically all he does is [ __ ]
bag on Disney and he was just a big Star
Wars fan he got pissed off at Disney
Star Wars uh Doom [ __ ] but I don't
remember the name of the Damn Channel
they dress up like an alien he with the
mask and he's got a bat uh
background like he's in a UFO and
Cthulhu is with him and he's got little
characters and they're just talking
about
the politics happening inside Disney
between Bob Iger and the other guys he
knows all the executives and then
they'll he's got sources inside Disney
leaking to him and and the sources turn
out to be correct or what's happening
who's going to get fired and why and uh
why these movies why certain movies suck
that they make and why other ones are
good and they were really supporting uh
the Mandalorian you know and the guy
that was running uh which is which is
named John prevot favro Favreau yeah
they really liked him that was a guy
from Mandalorian they were rooting for
him and
there were people in the company that
was trying to step on his work and
Destroy his to try to destroy his work
and behind his back and
the disappointment of Boba Fett That
Boba Fett series didn't turn out good
and the Obi-Wan Kenobi mini-series thing
[ __ ] evidently was disappointing and
uh but they Mandalorian season one and
two at least still was good
you know I thought it was pretty good
yeah I mean I'm not so much averse to
criticism like I'm not saying that you
know you should just have a channel like
talking about every everything is like
you know unicorn farts and rainbows and
stuff but I don't really like ones that
their whole like thing is just like
[ __ ] on other things like that it
gets really boring to me and I don't
really like Conflict for the sake of
conflict I just don't enjoy that it just
gives me a headache because it's like I
have enough stress in my life I don't
like need more stress added to it well
like like look at a show that I really
like
um you know welcome to the basement
which is just the two guys and they you
know they have like a little thing at
the beginning where they kind of talk
about some [ __ ] and then they watch a
movie and you know it's just like a
random movie it's old ones it's usually
old ones but sometimes new ones do and
then you know sometimes they love them
sometimes they hate them but they always
have like a really good discussion
afterward about what they liked and what
they didn't like they're not shouting
they're not like [ __ ] on people for
the sake of [ __ ] on them they're
just saying well you know I don't really
like it because of this and that and the
other thing and they they know a lot
about movies so their opinions are very
informed yeah it's I think my problem is
just kind of people that are just like
ranting about yeah oh everything sucks
and bloody yeah Ben's got yeah his name
is Overlord DVD that's right
Overlord DVD and that that channel
though isn't isn't like that that
channel was rooting for for the good
Star Wars but telling you that you know
that John paveau had it right the other
ones were [ __ ] it up and they were
correct he was correct
I think most people can agree there's
people that know the channels I'm
talking about in there
you'd like it it's kind of like the
motif of the show was kind of like the
newer MST you know it's kind of like
cartoonish little little sets and stuff
it's like that
and um
the problem with Disney is
is the corporation the people that are
in the corporation they they didn't make
good products on purpose because they're
they're not talented uh and then the
talent that they did have
was getting stepped on because they were
jealous you know what I mean his [ __ ]
was better and
you got to watch Duke you gotta watch
Overlord DVD he explains it as it
happens well I'm not that interested in
Disney stuff right so I probably
wouldn't watch I think because there's
like lots of other stuff yeah but you
know he was focusing mostly on Star Wars
that's what I'm saying which like I like
Star Wars and everything but I don't
really need to see like tons and tons of
stuff it's it's not something that I
would go like out of my way to like
watch stuff he was doing other things
like Indiana Jones and you know he could
get into that and uh you know like big
Classics but
most of the time when I was watching it
and get notifications it was having to
do with the Disney Corporation and Star
Wars
it's a good show though Midnight's Edge
is better though and then some people
talk about Geeks and Gamers I think that
guy was was Jeremy from Geeks he he was
a good dude and he I agreed with him you
know uh
independently we came to the same
conclusion that
the force awakens wasn't bad I thought
Force awakens was going to turn into
something good but then the other two
when I saw Brian Johnson's [ __ ] mess
I was like oh no they're making this up
as they're going along then the third
movie was they tried to save it and
retconned a bunch of [ __ ] and it had
some good ideas in it but it was just a
[ __ ] mess uh the third one they just
try to jam so much into their
and there's no characters really it's
just a
great special effects that's what it had
great special effects not much I and a
lot of it borrowed from
Knights of the Old Republic and good
video games but it's all just kind of
mad
because they basically kind of had the
star Forge in it from Knights of the Old
Republic
uh and it just the storytelling was poor
bad writing you know
Zach says Jenny did you say you liked my
story idea or was that someone else yeah
that was me I really really like that
idea I actually hope you I hope you do
it because remember I said I really
really like
um anything like that that's kind of
like True Crime sort of but also set in
like kind of Academia or like in art
kind of kind of situations I really like
that idea
uh Hugo said I really liked your
Universal monsters reviews Universal
monsters have a lot of fans I think
those reviews will generate a lot of
likes in the long run yeah probably I
mean I kind of feel like it's better I
mean I kind of like doing I don't know
it's like really hard balance to strike
usually I just pick random movies like
when I'm going through like seeing
what's available I'm like oh I wanted to
watch that again or I've been wanting to
see that and I just pick it without like
thinking too much about it
but it does seem to be kind of a sweet
spot between
older stuff that is beloved but maybe
not as
um hasn't been covered by a lot of
channels because like I said I feel like
we got a lot of
traction like early on in the channels
Days by covering Logan's Run which back
then didn't really have that many
reviews of it you know what I mean but
it was one of those movies that a lot of
people had seen like in the 1970s or saw
when they were kids but there wasn't a
lot of
other coverage of it and I think we hit
that sweet spot there but it's really
really hard to get that well we were
respectful to that property and I think
a lot of people appreciated that because
well I'm talking I was talking about
goof on it I was talking about the movie
actually not the series I talked about
the whole property yeah we were
respectful that whole property and
people recently
um somebody thanked us for how we
treated the series saying thank you for
not [ __ ] on it because everybody
else kind of shits on it I'm like why
wouldn't it [ __ ] on it I actually liked
it yeah it was good you know what I mean
for the budget and the thing about it I
I don't really like I said I don't like
to [ __ ] on things across the board even
if I do [ __ ] on things because you guys
have seen like um especially like some
of my book reviews and stuff like that
like sometimes I will have to call
people out for like you know terrible
grammar or something like that and even
then I just really really don't like to
do it because I guess as somebody that
writes books myself and somebody that
makes things it's like you really really
hate to like pour all of this work into
something and then put it out in the
world and everybody just shits on it you
know what I mean so I always kind of
like to temper criticism with something
good because it's like I know how that
feels like to put something out and then
like everybody just shits on but there's
a big difference between
[ __ ] on the work of one person okay
who's put a lot into it right a small
team has put a lot into it and say
[ __ ] on a huge Star Wars movie well
yeah it was not the product of one
person it was a product of a [ __ ] two
or three fighting committees
inside well and the thing about that
though is that even if you do [ __ ] on it
it's like it's not gonna make one
goddamn bit of difference like so if
you're yelling if it makes a lot of
money then they're just gonna keep doing
it so it's just kind of like I don't
really see the point of it well what it
is is that you can bemoan the fact that
[ __ ] that this is now a totally
corporate soulless property you know
it's sad because they don't have to be
there were other big budget movies that
did have souls like The Dark Knight
Series yeah that moved that that was a
great series for
as many fingers that were in that
[ __ ] pie you know what I mean as much
money it was behind that and the fact
that Studios [ __ ] tend to meddle and
[ __ ]
The Dark Knight series is very good
because it feels like a unified vision
of one storyteller and the quality is
consistently good through every one of
those movies
just gotta say it you know big studios
can make coherent good stories when they
want to or when they're allowed to
Richard Brown also says Hammer films
reviews get a lot of views on other
channels yeah I noticed that too and
actually I've been wanting to do more
Hammer films just because I feel like we
haven't done that many and I just and I
didn't even think about like more people
would watch the universal monsters ones
it's just I felt bad because I'm like
man we need to go back and like do some
more old Universal monsters or like you
know movies from the 50s and stuff like
that
um you know just because I wanted to do
them personally and kind of the same
thing too like with the hammer ones well
I know we've done a few Hammer movies
but I think we've done uh Horror of
Dracula twins of evil a couple of other
ones I can't how we doing on time we're
fine it's only it's only 7 30. okay
we're fine and like I said I don't
I don't have a whole lot to do no I just
gotta change clothes and put a different
wig on I already did the makeup and [ __ ]
so that's the longest thing and I
already kind of pretty much know what
I'm gonna wear so it's not that bad
um but yeah so uh grafters also said you
could have weirdos as guests too
in cells mgtows uh good no thanks
I started getting a situation no thanks
you started getting in a situation where
you got guests that are [ __ ] bogging
the show down too you know and we're not
doing three to four hour shows so far if
we had a but the more guests you have on
the show
and the less of a coherent or or cogent
topic the longer that thing's going to
be it's going to be all over the place
so you got to really be careful you got
to keep control of everything and I kind
of feel like too sometimes like the more
guests that you have like you're not
really getting I kind of feel like
anything over four is probably too many
because then like nobody like everybody
isn't get like there's always going to
be like one or two people that are
getting left out or aren't talking as
much because there's always going to be
one in one group that's gonna like Yap
and like [ __ ] hog all the attention
you know what I mean the only show I've
seen where they have five or six guys
that makes [ __ ] senses be like
Midnight's Edge
um
Geeks and Gamers can do it
um and that's just because they all know
each other and they're talking about a
subject and they go like a round table
and they'll ask what do you think what
do you think what do you think and then
they all go yeah that's probably what's
happening with this that's why that's
why it's taking so long so you know
yeah it's better than working on
something together and you yeah and if
you have kind of like a structure
because I kind of feel like if it's just
this amorphous like you don't have a
structure like everybody's going to be
talking over one another or like I said
one person's gonna be hogging you know
the microphone and no one else is going
to get a word and edgewise and it's like
all that kind of stuff so you know yeah
and it's usually tends to be a team of
guys working on a problem or ask trying
to answer a question or trying to figure
out why something is turning out a
certain way I remember so they're
working on something all right let me go
back and let's see uh
okay go ahead
Jenny going to the restroom telling me
yeah mangos thinks that he agrees with
me that Midnight's Edge is a good
Channel maybe the best of itself that's
because
Midnight's Edge will have a guests on
that are
like
right from the horse's mouth like when
they were talking when they when they
were talking about Conan how that
property should really kind of be
brought back
um it was in that damn
what is it
that Howard [ __ ] what was the name of
it
the the whole property was kind of in
the care of a single man of the what was
it Robert E Howard I think what his name
was and um it was in some kind of a
I forgot what they called it
was like a conservation Society type of
deal
to uh make sure that his his legacy was
protected and they weren't going to pimp
Conan out to some [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know Google owned [ __ ] property
where they were gonna turn Conan into
some kind of [ __ ] toxic masculinity
something or other anything like that
they was going to have to be
legitimate Conan material
and evidently that's and they'd have the
guy who was in charge of the who owned
that property and in charge of
protecting Howard's material and they
had him on there as a guest
and that was a great show any guy
answered a lot of questions they're not
gonna there's not gonna be any
second-rate Conan [ __ ] when it comes
to film
uh it's got to be something First Rate
with a good director and with a script
that is worthy of of a Howard book you
know and that
is
um close to the
character from the book
which the the best movie of Kodak would
be Arnold Schwarzenegger's first one
Conan the Barbarian the second one isn't
that good
uh it's really not it's kind of a shame
because that actually that could have
kicked ass it could have kicked ass but
it did uh and it's because they didn't
have the right writing and you don't
have John millius millius knew how to
[ __ ] write a story and it's a it's
actually a self-contained story
when all the stuff that was cut out of
it is put back in it and I've seen some
deleted scenes that's like oh which
explained a lot you know
like um
Conan and super Thai talking about the
spring wind
and you know the freaking which explains
a lot about the eye of the serpent that
he got from from Valeria and it has to
do with reproduction and a man's
reproductive years you know and he's
saying super Thai why are we in here
fighting this war we could be out you
know uh basically being fathers and
raising children and having a wife and
smelling the spring wind and all this
kind of [ __ ]
and uh super ties basically basically
says uh yeah we could but uh that's not
for us you know I gotta look at your
ugly ass you know that's
well gee thanks I love you too that's
not for you that's not for us I gotta
look at your ugly face
and uh Coney was like yeah I guess so
you know I guess so sorry you know
so that kind of it had to do with the
the eye of the serpent that [ __ ]
Valeria took from the [ __ ] serpent
Temple which all that [ __ ] has to do
with ashra you know El shaddai's wife
the fertility goddess it's it's it it's
the
Hera basically
you know another version of Hera
um
female goddess so basically what you
have is you have these warlord dudes
stealing feminine power to to entrance
women to make a cult of [ __ ]
accountables
that
that
living up in a damn mountain and it's a
circular firing squad and they don't do
anything they don't make anything
they're not productive they just eat
their own you know and that's that's
Millie is talking about Marxism that's
what he's exactly what he's talking
about Milius was a [ __ ]
anti-communist
and he's using all that [ __ ] is all
symbolic philosophy it was it's a great
work of of Mythology
and
um Nichi and philosophy
it'd be hard to make a sequel to that
because now what are you gonna he there
was gonna be a Trilogy he said he was
going to make three of them but Dino
DiLaurentis didn't have the money to do
the other two they they chose a cheaper
wrote they wanted a a PG movie that kids
could go see and they dumped it down a
lot and then it came out with Conan
Destroyer which
it's not a bad movie but it's not
Amelia's flick it's not R-rated
it's a kind of like a Conan Marvel comic
book kind of although the Conan Marvel
comic books I remember him as a kid
being pretty good
with [ __ ] evil monkey man and [ __ ]
kind of like Orcs And giant lizards and
fighting yetis and you know Conan was
like badass you know
Michael said I didn't know there was a
huge cult following of bad movies yeah
oh yeah yeah well like I said I don't
think MST 3K was completely responsible
for that because I think that existed
before them but I think them being
around like really helped and to be
honest with you there's something like
not all bad movies some movies are just
bad and like boring and you don't want
to sit through them but some movies are
bad in a really really Charming way and
I would argue and I don't know um you
know I've never taken like a film
studies class or anything like that or
like you know gone to filmmaking school
but I would hope that along with showing
you all the classic films I think they
should show you bad ones too because a
lot of times I think you can learn more
about filmmaking watching bad movies
than you can watching good ones but then
there are some bad movies that know that
they're bad
but the writing and the production
quality and the tone
is is is so good or so or no it is in
such a way where that movie becomes
really good yeah okay because it's kind
of self-aware
and um but see that can go either way
like because sometimes like I said then
sometimes you have the movies that were
made like for example for the Sci-Fi
channel where it's like they made
deliberately bad movies
some of those like Sharknado and stuff
like that Sharknado was entertaining
although it wasn't as funny as it could
have been I kind of feel like it could
have been funnier yeah um but okay you
know what I mean but then other times
they made ones but you could tell they
were trying really hard like to make a
self-aware bad movie and it's just not
as funny to me it's funnier to me
usually if they thought they were making
a good movie yeah they [ __ ] it up
whether you can mock up that's like
Manos has a fake yeah they thought they
were making hair okay and they [ __ ] it
up but the the Citizen Kane of bad
movies for me personally is velocipaster
velocity Pastor is a work of Genius
all right uh it's a it's a low budget
movie that knows what it is it knows who
the audience is and it is just
entertaining as [ __ ]
and it it does kind of make fun of
itself but it's just good and right
underneath that I'd probably put Nazis
at the center of the Earth
that was a lot of fun Nazi to the Center
of the Earth and what made Nazis at the
center of the earth great
is that as bad [ __ ] crazy as it was it
was very accurate
to
German
science fiction that
the Nazis liked because they they had
you know they liked
there was German science fiction that
they were into and that's kind of
influenced in this movie
is you just have to see it to understand
it like there's
they go to
Germans German science fiction talked a
lot about Hollow Earth
okay that there was another Earth inside
the earth that you could go on the inner
crust
and there's another Earth in there this
is [ __ ] ridiculous but they had they
had that in German science fiction okay
so they're in this movie there is a
hollow Earth
and in there
it's basically reanimated
Joseph Goebbels
[ __ ] Heinrich himmler's in there
Adolf Hitler's in there and he's [ __ ]
they got his head and his uh it's
preserved and it's on a damn robot body
he's a Mecca it's like Mecca yeah and
they built a [ __ ] Fleet of it's
hilarious they built a fleet of
frill saucers which they believed in
frill energy they liked real energy they
were looking for real energy
evidently it's hard to say and making
flying saucers which there is some
evidence that some guys in Germany were
working on something like a flying
saucer
um
some say that they did it was like a
helicopter more than else but it's hard
to say it's hard to know it's true it's
been a long time it's been a long time
well and yeah go ahead I would argue too
that I think one of the things that
makes velocir
like a good bad movie in the sense that
it knows that it's a bad movie yeah but
it's not so self-aware it's not like
winking at you it's not like trying to
be cleverer than it is I think what
makes that one work is that it's very
earnest
it comes across as like very charming
and like I said that's really really
hard to pull off yeah
um and I think that's why a lot of
deliberately like movies that were
deliberately made to be bad movies don't
work because they're too
self-aware you know so they're they're
winking at the audience they're very
sarcastic they're very and it's like it
just comes off as like not I don't know
there's something like kind of arrogant
about it that that I don't like yeah
that tone is not in this movie but it
does it does do some of that but it it
works you just have to see the movie
philosophaster is the best bad movie
oh if you ask me well at least the best
the best bad movie that was deliberately
made to be a bad movie yeah yeah if
you're if you're interested if you're
talking about movies like like I said
like you know birdemic or the room or
something like that that's your
Masterpiece those people and Neil
Breen's movie somebody mentioned him
um those people that made those actually
think they're making good movies they
are just sorely sorely mistaken and
that's what makes them funny yeah is
that they're like just batshitting
they're wrong yeah is that they're wrong
they're just terrible yeah but they're
terrible in like a really funny
entertaining way yeah well green
he has a messiah complex yeah a big time
he casts himself in every movie as being
the savior of mankind he's either
basically Jesus or an Angelic being or a
superior alien or something like that
and all the women love him in the movies
and he's teaching the world how to
[ __ ] save itself from itself type of
deal and he has the power to do so and
the women just love him okay but when
you look at neo-brain Neil brain is a
very average man yeah very average and
he casts these young hotties to just
[ __ ] worship him through the whole
[ __ ] movie basically see and that
will never not be funny and it's
hilarious okay because this is obviously
because it's like very transparent
transparent ego fantasy sure okay yeah
and he's putting this out to the world
so you can be a part of his fantasy
that's what I mean it's like sick it
would we'll yeah see okay here's the
thing I kind of feel like a lot of
people enjoy like whether they're
writers or whatever it is they do like
everybody enjoys a little ego stroke and
now and then right and it's like you
want to write like kind of a fantasy
kind of thing where you're putting
yourself and you're the hero and [ __ ]
like that like I get that I don't think
I've ever done that but I know like a
lot of people do
so there's nothing wrong with that I
think what I think the problem arises
thank you very much Sly how you been bro
oh thank you sorry I had to get back up
because I yeah I can't see it yet which
I'm down to the bottom but I think the
problem arises when you put it out into
the world thinking that it's like good
and that everybody's not gonna know that
that's like what you're doing I'm like
it's it's fine if you just keep it for
yourself and be like yeah I'm awesome
you know what I mean but he's like look
I'm awesome and as everybody's like no
you're really not yeah
the Filipino guy who did birdemic and
the other one where he get James Nyan I
think James
and his [ __ ] is just man
well his shit's entertaining just
because it's so strange it's like you
actually you can't you're watching it
being like why on Earth would anyone
make that decision that they made and
like it happens over and over again it's
mind-boggling he's an older guy he
looked like a boomer he's older than me
he's got to be I mean he looks like a he
seems like a very very nice man yeah he
seems like a very nice man every like
interview I've seen with him he doesn't
seem like a weirdo or nothing he's a
Filipino Boomer
making movies for a western audience and
he doesn't really understand Western
culture thank you Sly by the way yeah I
just saw it he doesn't really understand
he doesn't really understand Western
culture and he makes a lot of weird
decisions
especially about dating
and Western women
and some of the [ __ ] he thinks that some
of the [ __ ] he thinks is possible and
then
there's always some kind of a an
environmental message behind it but it's
real ham-handed
like it's obvious in burdemic whoever
gave him the money to or partially gave
him the money to make this movie we're
selling solar panels it's a company that
sold solar panels don't you mean solar
panels solar power because of that the
lead in the movie is constantly talking
about solar panels but he can't
pronounce he says solar panels solar
panels and no we're not even
exaggerating yeah that's how he says it
and he they mentioned solar panels
regularly
all right in in the [ __ ] movie but
the movie's not about solar panels or
the movie is about these birds it's
basically uh it's basically a rip-off on
Albert Hitchcock's the bird and it was
called the birds yeah yeah it's a rip
off of that based on a Daphne yeah and
they're jumping out with [ __ ]
AR-15s
with just empty bags in them and they
get they're they're pretending to shoot
at the birds and they just got CG muzzle
blasts coming off as well NCG Birds too
CG birds so they don't even bother
buying a damn blank adapter
look we had to adapt to adapt those
things to Blanks is that's it the R15 is
the cheapest easiest thing to adapt to
Blanks you just pull the [ __ ] muzzle
off of the branch
put a new washer muzzle washer in there
or you can take the old one and beat it
into shape
and then I got a different flash
suppressor on there it's got a little
small hole and that's what you use for
Hollywood black adapter you put that on
there and you can get
556 or M16 or M249 blanks off the
internet for [ __ ] next to nothing and
same magazine and everything you won't
have a full auto trigger package but it
won't matter you can add full auto
sounds and they can just pull the
trigger fast and the average person
can't wouldn't notice that you know hey
there's not enough muzzle blasts coming
out of that to match up with the sound
you know and it it would look like you
were really shooting you know and there
was no reason to even show The Birds
getting hit you could show that a
different shot and then other shots of
birds falling on the ground you don't
need it all to be in camera in camera at
the same time but the CG was just
[ __ ] ridiculous well I'm over
analyzing this [ __ ] stupid burden I'm
telling you though that it's like you
really think that they were going to do
real muzzle blasts or real birds when in
one of his other movies which is called
replicas which is like a Sci-Fi type
movie they don't even have real
backgrounds they have actors standing in
front of a green screen and then it's
like some stock sci-fi e-looking
background and it's very obviously yeah
but like the lighting doesn't match or
anything
and he's like he probably thinks that
[ __ ] is just high tech that's what I
mean he's like ooh what do you mean I
can like pay a few hundred dollars a
year for this like uh you know Video
subscription service and I can buy all
these backgrounds and I can just slap my
actors in front of a green screen like I
said he doesn't try to match the
lighting or the color toning or anything
yeah like you know it's like he doesn't
know I guess but that's the thing I
think there's more to it than that I
think more like he doesn't care
I think it's somehow he's raising money
out of it
uh he's edwarding it somehow that's what
I was just gonna say like Edward I don't
know if Edward actually said this but
from the movie Edward that had Johnny
Depp anymore he's like No One's Gonna
notice
like like when tour Johnson like climbs
out of the graves I have like the
[ __ ] cardboard gravestones are
falling over No One's Gonna notice that
he's just trying to pay his rent that
month and [ __ ] get some groceries in
the [ __ ] and party a little bit
that's maybe making money a little bit a
little no I'm talking about that's what
it would yeah it would live day to day
Victor says just an idea but you should
revisit your more popular older shows
yeah we've been talking about doing that
actually we have done it a couple of
times yeah we've done uh the warrants
twice yeah and we did we just redid
video nasties too because we did that
one a long time ago
um and he said I noticed other podcasts
doing this you can read yeah so we could
yeah we could probably update stuff and
we could update stuff
um let me see I got like really behind
um let's see yeah I would have said the
room and then to talk about Neil Breen
um let's see Tom and Jenny how was your
holiday oh really good man we ate off
that uh turkey and all the sides for
like four days I think yeah it tastes a
little funny I'm throwing this turkey
out we ate most of it though we ate most
of it yeah Danny Rowling said what's Tom
and Jenny's favorite go-to Christmas
holiday film you like to watch I like uh
[ __ ] Christmas Chronicles with Kurt
Russell I like uh the first one the
first one the second one's okay but it's
not as good as the first one and then um
die hard yeah I like watching that one
we pretty much always watch Christmas
Chronicles yeah
last year we watched die hard yeah we
watched them both yeah we watched both
of those yeah I usually watch like I
said I usually watch The Mystery Science
Theater Christmas episodes yeah around
Christmas time
um I'm trying to think of other ones
hmm
I don't know I feel like we watched more
than that last those were the two that I
remember watching I remember watching
Christmas Chronicles I think we watched
both of them and then we watched die
hard too but I don't remember what other
ones we watched
I still kind of like the Christmas
specials like from when I was a kid like
the Grinch and Frosty the Snowman and
[ __ ] I still like those
um
Danny Rowling said some holiday
alcoholic eggnog taste testing would be
a cool Side Tracks episode hey that is a
good idea yeah remember how we started
doing that whole like we're gonna do
different like alcohol tasting like how
long did that [ __ ] last yeah it
didn't last two or three weeks well
that'll happen sometimes
run out of stuff to buy
well it's like it's not so much that
it's just yeah we would usually forget
about it and then you know and sometimes
we didn't have like enough money and
[ __ ] like that Tammy said uh you should
review some Hitchcock movies yeah that's
a good idea yeah I think all we've done
we've done the psycho movies right I
think we talked about all four psychos
somebody's trying to send uh somebody's
trying to send me some money but it
would it couldn't Super Chat I'm gonna
give her my cash app
I'll send a cash app in a bit
let me see let me turn it
so I said my go-to is always Christmas
Carol but seems every decade they get
darker yeah that's right actually oh
that's that reminds me last year yeah
last year I watched Muppet Christmas
Carol because I hadn't seen that in a
long time usually I actually kind of
like I like the Jersey Scott one the
best but the Muppet one is good too
uh Cheryl mackwood said I watch Black
Christmas and it's a wonderful life
every year weird combo yeah black
Christmas is another good one
I don't think we watched that one last
year but I think we watched it the year
before
um I want to see Violent night so bad it
looks awesome I kind of want to see that
too like I love David Harbor
and I've heard that it was like pretty
badass they have like a new Christmas
horror movie out now called violent
night felt like a killer Santa I think
does Tom make a special eggnog
no we usually just buy it yeah I'm not a
huge eggnog it's you know like one cup
of milk is one egg and almost like a an
unbelievable almost like a [ __ ]
one-third or a half a cup of sugar in it
and then there's going to be a little
bit of vanilla and then there's going to
be
um
uh nutmeg in it then you blend it
it's [ __ ] rich I think it might even
be a half a cup of sugar first well it's
basically like drinking melted ice cream
it's ice cream mix
I don't know why I just never got really
and I love ice cream and I love all that
kind of stuff but I don't know I just
never really got into eggnog
I can have a little bit but
I don't know I like it I know you do
like we usually we usually get Summer
yeah you got some the other day yeah I
got some downstairs yeah
yeah Tammy said I think Tom has a recipe
in the book doesn't he yeah I think yeah
I think we did put a recipe over there
yeah
and
American Military yeah we have a
cookbook people if you ever want a
cookbook just hit us up yeah that's
right it's a beautiful cookbook where is
it around here uh let's start plugging
all the products that we have
I don't remember where I put it it's
right here somewhere
don't ask me where [ __ ] is I don't know
yeah we sell [ __ ]
well see though I was thinking about
this the other day because I was like
I think sometimes
I don't know like I just I do so many
things and it's like I forget to bring
it up like I think people don't even
know that I design board games and I
have like a [ __ ] ton of them but it's
like I always just like forget to bring
it up you know what I mean because it's
just like something I did and it's like
yeah they're on sale somewhere but it's
like I don't really like think about it
even though that's pretty much like my
favorite thing to do I love [ __ ]
designing games
like board games if that was if I could
like make money just doing one thing and
I had enough money to live I'd probably
do that because it has everything in it
that I like like you can write a story
and like you can do like graphic design
and like make all the boxes and I love
doing that chick that kind of [ __ ]
um American Military 100 said have you
ever considered inviting or featuring
another podcast or any show like Dr
wolfula or the Angry Video Game Nerd or
something like that I hadn't actually
thought about that but
I don't know maybe we should one of
these days I really like Dr Wolfie he's
like super funny
but um
you know
uh let me see
they were like also said a comparison
episode of canned versus carton eggnog
would be sick
and then Tammy said I just made the
pumpkin soup out of the book the other
day very good thank you yeah
we made pumpkin soup though yeah like
last week yeah and he made Pumpkin Curry
pumpkin Thai curry yeah with chicken in
it that was really good
uh how do we find your board games if
you go to the game crafter and you have
to put the v in there it's like the
gamecrafter.com and then do a search on
um giallo games
g-i-a-l-l-o uh you should see all my
stuff on there I think I have a link in
the description box
if I remember correctly but I don't know
I have like a whole bunch of them
I don't know I just like making them
yeah Cheryl said the cookbook makes a
great Christmas gift yeah I mean
that was fun to do it took a long time
but I'm pretty happy with how it came
out
and it turned out pretty funny remember
how we did that I remember like I just
recorded you talking
like about all the episodes about all
the recipes yeah those recipes will be
talking about them yeah
pretty much like I just kind of like put
it in yeah text form now of course you
know I don't have all that [ __ ]
memorized I had to [ __ ] go back and
double check you know what I mean
[ __ ] all the the the the ratios and
the amounts but you know pretty much I
knew most of that offhand
and um
some of it's just like me joking around
about the history of it and then giving
giving tips on certain parts of the
cooking process if I remember correctly
yeah I was going through with how to do
it okay
all right he's got the message okay you
see him it gave him my um
um your cash out cash yeah yeah
somebody
that's great
yeah every little bit helps um yeah it's
almost time to uh end the show actually
it probably is yeah because it's a
little bit after eight and I gotta start
putting on my going out clothes
yeah am I going out wig
because I don't really want it this
one's like I like this one I've had this
one like a long time but like I said
it's kind of long and it catches on
everything and it's got
I guess I wore it out a few times and it
get like it got like knots in it and I
can't get him out thank you Senor sticks
I would like to design cell board games
how second he might I contacted it
published honestly I just go through the
game Crafter
and it's basically like a pod like print
on demand so all you do is you just go
in there and they have like a million
different
um
uh like game pieces that you can
customize and then they have like other
kind of peas like Dice and [ __ ] like
that and you just put together your game
like you upload the art and you know you
write your rules and everything like
that and you just pick out all of your
components and put them in it and like
if somebody orders it like you set up a
storefront on there and somebody orders
it then they print it out and send it so
now I the only thing is um you know it's
kind of expensive like you don't pay
anything but you don't get that much
like unless you charge a lot more like
over what the Pieces cost like what the
components cost but
um you know because some of the
components are I don't know they're not
like super super expensive but they are
like a little bit pricey so you usually
have to like price the game
a little bit higher maybe than
than something similar on the market but
you know
but it's a it's a cool site I mean they
have like I don't know if there's other
ones out there like that that's kind of
like the only one that I know of
but
Sly is laughing at my saying going out
wig
well I have my other one that's also
blue but shorter than this it's like
easier to wear and it's not like as
knotted up as this one I didn't realize
this one was like so naughty but it
looks kind of like that naughty well you
know naughty girl not naughty I mean not
a k n o t t y do you know what I mean
yeah but yeah check out it's the game
crafter you have to put the th e at the
beginning the gamecrafter.com and they
have templates and they have all they
have all different kind of cards they
have
um
just anything you can possibly think of
uh you know you can have a little like
fake money printed you can have and they
even have like a little part shop like a
little component shop they have stuff
where you can cut like plastic pieces
out with lasers like all that kind of
stuff like it's really really cool you
can get like pretty much anything you
want on there and you can like put it
all together into one box so that's what
I use so you don't have to put any money
up front or anything you just if
somebody buys your game you just get a
percentage you know what I mean yeah uh
Tammy says have fun tonight thanks for a
great show thank you guys very much for
coming and hanging out with us on Friday
night like you always do I know you
they're always here for us isn't that
nice
yeah everybody's helping us they're
helping us out yeah thank you very much
we're gonna uh keep hitting hitting up
the the main audience and the bigger
shows so please bear with us we just got
to advertise yeah once we advertise when
we get to uh get the count back up again
we'll we'll we'll we'll be we'll be okay
yeah just uh try to we're gonna try to
expand get some more patrons And
subscribe to Jenny's other channel so we
can get those monetized yeah go to she's
almost monetized as it is scare Salon
yeah and crime and Memorial those are my
other two channels yeah uh we need to
start promoting links for those maybe
like on uh
on uh on our Channel somehow yeah or
maybe on Instagram or or something or
well I do post I do Post like and and I
usually post if I post if I put up a
video on one of those channels I usually
put it in the community tab on this
channel all right so so there's links to
it yeah but yeah I'm trying to get those
two monetized and you need a thousand
subscribers so they haven't been up that
long so I'm trying to get everybody
maybe in the description box in the in
the chat on each video that we put up
put a link to the other thank you mango
Mango's putting up all the okay all the
links thank you we need to put those in
maybe in the description box of the
video itself too
yeah that's what I would do that's right
that way they can open the description
box and the links will be in there to
the other channel yeah because I put
links to pretty much everything else but
I think I forgot to put those in there
yeah
um oh what I was gonna say was that I
think
we're not going to be back till Monday
like for haunting Mondays because
normally we would do a matinee on Sunday
but I'm gonna go see my sister yeah on
Sunday because she's having her birthday
dinner and the evening so I'm gonna go
over and like eat with her in a
restaurant yeah over by Disney
so we probably won't do a show on Sunday
but we will do our haunting show on
Monday like usual so have a good weekend
you guys yeah thank you guys very much
and thank you guys very much for hanging
out with us and we will see you guys
again on Monday
good night